Da sind wir und ich hoffe, dass der Stream 48 FPS hat, hoffentlich stimmt das jetzt
was, ja wunderbar. Moment, stopp der Chat geht nicht, geht der Chat? Alter lahm geht
der Chat, mal testen, der Chat geht nicht, Chat ist broken, jetzt geht der Chat, perfekt,
ich wäre auch gern zu Hause zu sorgen. Ja, IRL ne. Ich habs mir auch überlegt, aber
ich hatte kein Bock, außerdem wisst ihr ja, ich habs nicht so mit großen, mit sozialen
Events mit vielen Leuten. So die große Preisfrage ist, was wir heute Abend machen, ich hab keine
Ahnung, also, entweder grind ich meine BDO-Dailys jetzt erstmal, dass so viele jetzt überhaupt
da sind, ist schon wieder geil. Gibt noch mehr No-Life-Leute wie ich. Moment, den Eax
kann ich jetzt gerade mal anschreiben, ob wir nachher Placements machen wollen in Overwatch.
Moment, das gucken wir jetzt gerade mal. Wir gucken gerade mal. Die Blizzard App, heißt
die jetzt wieder Blizzard App oder Battle.net App? Das ist geil, die heißt wieder Battle.net
App, ne? Leute, ich muss mal kurz meinen Browser-Tab refreshen, so ich seh jetzt kurz nicht,
wenn ihr was im Chat schreibt. Ja, jetzt sollte es eigentlich wieder gehen. Ja. Gucken wir
doch mal. Mal sehen wir doch gerade mal aus. Ich starte das Game mal schnell. Window-Capture,
nein. Hallo? Warum geht das nicht? Eigentlich möchte ich jetzt... Ah, Moment, Moment, man
macht kein Window-Capture, man muss Game-Capture machen, weil OBS sagt, das muss so sein. Ja,
das funktioniert jetzt auch. Ok, wir gucken jetzt mal, ist denn die neue Season schon
on, weil dann können wir auch die Placements machen, wenn ich den Eax dazu kriege, Placements
zu machen. Ne, das hat... 3 Stunden ist zu lang. Also wir können jetzt ja schlecht 3 Stunden
hier einfach nur da sitzen. Voodoo-Cloud muss arbeiten. Meinst du jetzt? Meinst du jetzt
oder morgen? Morgen ist doch Feiertag. I'll be your Ukraine. Ok, also die Overwatch-Season
ist nicht live. Dann mache ich mal BDO an und crying einfach mal ein bisschen, bis wir
eine Ahnung haben, was wir machen können. Also wir haben auch noch zur Auswahl, dass
wir entweder, also entweder, zwei Sachen, die zur Auswahl stehen, Moment, ich logg mich
jetzt erst mal kurz ein. Zwei Sachen, die zur Auswahl stehen, sind entweder ich mache
mal ein BDO, mein BDO daily grind, 300 Basis killen, 300 Centaurs killen, 300 Cuttreys killen
oder irgendwie sowas. Vielleicht mache ich das. Oder wir spielen Plants vs. Zombies fertig,
also das erste Tower-Defense-Spiel. Da sind wir jetzt ja quasi im letzten Drittel angekommen,
also ich mache jetzt erstmal ein BDO an. Oder aber, was wir auch machen können, was wir auch
machen können ist, wir gucken uns Katzenvideos an. Wir gucken uns Katzenvideos an, easy, oder?
BDO ist eigentlich offen, BDO sollte jetzt angezeigt werden. BDO wieder angezeigt. Wir
können uns Katzenvideos angucken, wir gucken uns jetzt, süße Katze ist sehr anhänglich,
wir gucken uns jetzt an. Oh, die ist aber echt süß. Oh, was die für Geräusche macht.
Oh, oh, kleines Katzi. Ah, ist das ein süßes Katzilein. Joa. Die will nicht weg.
Ach, ist das niedlich. Kleines, feines Katzi. Ja, so muss das sein. Vor allem wenn es heute
so knallt. Haben sie wieder Schiss. So, ich glaube nicht, dass wir uns den ganzen Abend
Katzenvideos angucken wollen, oder? Erstmal den Viztacht einlocken. Deine Schicht beginnt
um 23 Uhr. Ich arbeite in der Rezeption in einem 5-Sterne-Hotel. Ah, um 7.30 Uhr habe
ich dann Feierabend. Das ist natürlich eine Scheißzeit. So, jetzt rennen wir erstmal
zurück in irgendeine Stadt. Wir rennen jetzt zurück zu unserem Gaul und reiten mal zu unserem
Richtung Craning-Spot hoch. Silvester in Black Desert. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Also,
wie gesagt, es steht so aus, weil entweder gucken wir uns Katzenvideos anspielen im Video,
oder wir spielen Plants vs. Zombies fertig. Na, oder wir könnten Viewer Games in Overwatch
machen. Das geht natürlich auch. Das geht natürlich auch. Moment, Evoli, weißt du,
wie man Pols machen kann? Was heißt das? Pols? Pool? Pol, oder? Eine Abstimmung. Also,
wir haben zur Auswahl Katzenvideos, wobei das nicht wirklich ernst gemeint ist, aber
das können wir mal reinschreiben. Also, zur Auswahl stehen für die Abstimmung Katzenvideos.
Das gewinnt jetzt wahrscheinlich, wenn ich das mit reinschreibe. Egal, das schreiben
wir mit rein. Katzenvideos, Overwatch Custom Matches, also oder, bzw. Viewer Games, BDO,
oder BDO Daily Mob Grind, oder Plants vs. Zombies. Kampagne fertig machen. So, ich mach
mal einen Poll. Ne, ich mach schon. Straw Poll, oder wie das ging. So, gucken, dass ich
jetzt nicht in irgendwelche Mops reinrenne. Oh, ich mach mal, ich mach mal eine Abstimmung.
Also, was wollen wir? Ach, Overwatch, wie schreibt das? Viewer Games. Black Desert Daily
Mob Grind, oder aber Plants vs. Zombies. Kampagne fertig. Das wird allerdings nicht
bis 24 Uhr ausreichen, Plants vs. Zombies Kampagne. Generell, es muss ja nichts davon
werden, bis 24 Uhr auslassen, man kann ja mehrere Sachen machen. Ok, Poll. So, einmal
abstimmen, please. Wir könnten auch ganz, ganz abgedrehte Sachen machen. Katzenvideos
auf der einen Seite und Plants vs. Zombies auf der anderen. So, ich reite jetzt aber
erstmal hoch, ich muss hier eh weg. Welches Food ist denn hier dran? Wir müssen eh irgendwo
rein, da ist es auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht, bei einer alten Nova zu reiten. Dass wir den
Katzenvideos, wie gesagt, das ist nicht wirklich ernst gemeint, ne? Es war ja klar, dass die
Katzenvideos gewinnt. Hast du keine EAS-Umbroker Korthüllen? Doch, Korthüllen habe ich noch.
Ich warte mal in den Reacts, ob er mitspielen will, falls wir Overwatch machen. Brings die
Quali ein bisschen besser sein, hoffe ich. Ich habe jetzt auf 48 FPS runtergestellt und
Slower auf Medium. Encoding Zeit, also es müsste jetzt ein bisschen besser aussehen
ohne zu ruckeln als gestern. Um Null über Placements? Ja, ich weiß, wir können nicht
vorher Placements machen. Okay, also es ist bis jetzt ziemlich exakt gleich Stand zwischen
Overwatch Custom Games und Plants vs. Zombies Kampagne und gefolgt von BDO. Gewonnen haben
natürlich die Katzenvideos, das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt noch mindestens mal nebenbei
ein, zwei süße Katzenvideos angucken. Dann würde ich vorschlagen, spielen wir jetzt
erstmal Plants vs. Zombies fertig. Wir spielen erstmal Plants vs. Zombies fertig und danach
machen wir Overwatch Games, da können wir uns nämlich aufwärmen für Null über Placements.
Okay, jetzt haben wir die Plants vs. Zombies Kampagne und Plants vs. Zombies Kampagne.
Reb, Rebdoka, was wolltest du denn haben? So, oh ne, oh jetzt wirds grausam wieder. Jetzt
müssen wir mal Plants vs. Zombies erstmal wieder einstellen, dass man das Game richtig
sieht. Okay, euer, ich ahne wieder Schlemmes. Ich ahne ganz Schlemmes. Okay, dann versuch
ich das jetzt mal zu crabben. Geht nicht. Okay, das wolltest du wahrscheinlich wieder
mit Game Capture machen. Das ist echt immer kompliziert, so ganzen Kackgames zu crabben.
Kann das sein, dass Plants vs. Zombies wieder nicht erkannt wird oder was? Oh, jetzt ist
wieder, der OBS Struggle ist wieder real. Das müssen wir jetzt erstmal wieder einstellen,
aber ich weiß ja noch wie es funktioniert hat. Moment, Moment, ich hab die hier noch
drin, Window Capture. Nein, das sind die Katzenvideos. Geht doch. So, jetzt müssen wir das Game leider
wieder ganz eklig verschieben. So, easy. Okay, BDO muss ich jetzt, ich muss jetzt erstmal
in BDO noch, ich muss jetzt erstmal in BDO noch, wir müssen jetzt zumindest noch hoch
reiten, sonst sitz ich hier am Arsch der Welt. Wir müssen jetzt noch mal kurz hier hin reiten,
dann können wir weitermachen. Stretched. Ja, es geht nicht anders, das Game ist 4 zu 3.
Ich frag mich wie das auf der, so und während ich reite gucken wir uns noch Katzenvideos
an. Oh, die ist aber auch echt süß.
So ein kleines, feines Katzi. Jetzt drück doch mal Shift Mensch, warum soll ich Shift
drücken? Hä? What? What Alter? Was? Shift? So, nächstes, was haben wir sonst noch für
Katzenvideos zur, zu was haben wir sonst noch für Katzenvideos zur Auswahl hier? Dann
rennt mein Pferd schneller, ich kann jetzt aber nicht auf YouTube gucken und mein Pferd
schneller rennen lassen, das funktioniert nicht. Ich mach jetzt das, was laut Abstimmung
am meisten gewünscht wurde und das sind auf einmal jetzt BDO Dailygrind. What the fuck?
Wollt ihr mich rollen oder was? Eben war Plants vs. Zombies Kampagne noch erster, noch erster
und jetzt ist BDO Mob Dailygrind und Overwatch Custom Games vorne. Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Wo kann man hier abstimmen? Ja Moment, Schicks noch mal. So. Also Leute, ich gebe euch jetzt
noch mal 5 Minuten Zeit zum abstimmen. In der Zeit gucken wir Katzenvideos und ich reite
mit dem Pferd zum Grinding Spot und was dann oben ist, machen wir gefolgt vom anderen.
Es sei dann, es sei dann Overwatch und Plants vs. Zombies liegen relativ nah beieinander,
dann würde ich sagen, machen wir Overwatch zum Aufwärmen für die neue Season Richtung
Null Uhr. Evoli hat, was ist das für ein Video? Katze? Ok, Moment Evoli, jetzt gucken wir
uns jetzt an. BTF, was ist das? Das ist doch nachvertont, oder?
Ich kann gerade kein Chat lesen, ich muss gerade 3 sagen, gleichzeitig nachkommen. Krass.
Ich mach mal, ich mach mal die Musik aus, dass man das hört. Das ist doch krass. Aber
noch mal, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gehört habt. Das klingt, als will einer so fake rülpsen.
Das ist ja so Leute, die es nicht können richtig, die hören es schon auch so an. Wenn
ihr wisst, was ich meine, das ist aber hart. Ich hätte erst gedacht, das ist bearbeitet
oder so. Was kann man sonst noch für Katzenvideos zu bieten? Revo? Das hört sich an wie einer,
ich finde das hört sich voll an wie einer, der versucht so, wisst ihr früher war es
doch besonders cool, wenn man so, wenn man quasi so künstlich rülpsen konnte. Da fanden
sie sich alle geil, wenn sie es kommen. Und die Leute, die es nicht konnten, also inklusive
mir, ich habe mir das nie beigebracht, weil es irgendwie ziemlich sinnloser Skill ist,
die haben dann auch einfach gemacht, weil sie es nicht hingekriegt haben. So, was sagt
ihr jetzt? Also wir haben noch bis 35 Zeit abzustimmen, was wir machen sollen. Okay,
das ist aber alles so ziemlich ähnlich. Das Problem dabei ist, wenn das so total aufgesplittet
ist, wenn ich jetzt das eine mache, ist es nicht, was ein Drittel der Leute will. Wenn
ich das andere mache, ist es nicht, was ein Drittel der Leute will. Was auf jeden Fall
ein Viertel der Leute will ist Katzenvideos. Streamst du bis nächstes Jahr durch oder
gehst du kurz vor 24 Uhr auf. Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich auf gehe. Also ich streame
durch bis nächstes Jahr, allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht bis irgendwie morgen früh oder so.
So, was haben wir sonst noch? Ich weiß nicht, ich finde Katzenbaby-Videos gar nicht so
toll. Ich gucke am liebsten ehrlich gesagt Videos von ausgewachsenen Katzen. So dieses
Oh alle Katzenbabys sind so süß ist auch das Problem, dass sich Leute immer mehr Katzenbabys
kaufen und sie irgendwann ins Tierheim bringen, weil sie ja feststellen, dass Katzenbabys
auch mal groß werden. Dann lieber so eine oder? Die ist doch wirklich süß hier. Die
sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie Katz-FPS plus komplett halt, also vom Kopf her, plus wie
komplett andere Farbe. Lul Katzenvideos, ja. Ja ich muss erstmal zum Grinding Spot. So
was haben wir sonst noch hier? Katze fährt alleine S-Bahn. Die haben damit doch keine
Schmerzen. Ach das ist ja nicht mal ein Video, das ist ja dumm. So lange die Katze in Ruhe
lässt, ist es dennoch wurscht. Die legt sich dann da hin, denkt easy life. Hier wird in
der S-Bahn gelegen, was juckt mich der Rest drumherum? Wenn man süße Katze eingibt, gibt
es nur Babykatzen auf YouTube. Das finde ich so bescheuert. Ich gucke mir viel lieber
auch im... singt, nein das ist bestimmt dummes Video. Leichter Clickbait Titel würde ich
mal sagen. Die ist niedlich. Was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten? Die meisten funny
Katz-Kompilations finde ich nämlich auch überhaupt nicht funny. Ich finde vieles
generell nicht funny. Kennt ihr diese Videos, die im Titel haben irgendwie do not oder du
schaffst es nicht nicht zu lachen oder so diese Videos, wo dann irgendwie mit 10 Minuten
Video wetten du schaffst es, du hältst es nicht durch nicht zu lachen und sowas. Und
ich weiß schon quasi am Anfang des Videos, dass das eigentlich total lustig ist. So okay,
Abstimmung vorbei. Auf dem ersten Platz ist BDO Custom Games, auf dem zweiten Platz ist
Overwatch Custom Games, auf dem zweiten Platz BDO Daily Mob Crimes und Plants vs. Zombie
Kampagne. Allerdings ist alles so um die 30% rum. Eine 31%, andere 24%. Deswegen würde
ich sagen, machen wir einfach alles. Ich meine wir haben noch 2,5 Stunden Zeit, das geht.
Ich werde jetzt, wenn ich gerade schon dabei bin, wir machen Daily Catry Crime Quest, das
ist easy, das geht schnell. Und dann muss ich mal gucken, wenn der Eax da ist, machen
wir Custom Games. Eax, woher soll ich wissen, was du machen sollst, wenn dein Game ruckelt?
So, okay, mal gucken, ob er dabei ist, mal schauen. Ist das Black Desert Online? Ja,
ich stelle das mal auch kurz um, weil so in RL ist nicht wirklich richtig. Hat bei euch
die Stream Kategorie aktualisiert? Hat bei euch die Stream Kategorie aktualisiert? Also
ich hatte es jetzt eigentlich umgestellt auf Black Desert. Irgendwie hat es keinen Bock.
Okay dann Bug Twitch, da muss man das wahrscheinlich über das Dashboard machen. Ich mache es über
das Dashboard, über das Dashboard geht es immer. Twitch ist fast genauso kaputt wie
ich, er tut mittlerweile immer sowas. Ähm, Black Desert Online, Informationen aktualisieren.
So, jetzt sollte es aber geupdatet haben. Ne, vielleicht braucht das kurz. Was ist da
schon wieder kaputt? Twitch, please. Was, YouTube funktioniert doch super. YouTube funktioniert
super zum angucken, aber das YouTube, also dieses, dieses, wie nennt es sich, Creation
Center oder so, äh, Creator Studio, das ist ganz grausam. Das gibt mittlerweile sogar
intern zwei verschiedene Versionen, die man verwenden kann und dem einen geht das und
dem anderen geht das noch nicht, also, Google, ja. Okay, Informationen aktualisieren, Dashboard,
easy, live. So, jetzt steht es bei mir auf Black Desert, aber, ah jetzt, jetzt hat es
umgestellt, Leute, ne? Hat es bei euch auch umgestellt? Jetzt ist, jetzt ist richtig.
Jetzt steht es auf BDO. So, nice. Jetzt, jetzt hat es umgestellt. Twitch, ich hab das jetzt
dreimal gemacht, dreimal exakt das gleiche, aber Twitch hat es, nope, kein Bock. Wie
ist dein Familienname in BDO? Äh, Wubbel, was denkst du hier? Äh, Wubbel. Ähm, was
denn? Ah, Evoliso Videoswitch blöd hat irgendwie einer seine Katze in die Badewanne gesetzt.
Oder ihr gefällt's, aber ich find die guckt nicht so, als dass ihr gefällt. Ähm, was
sagst du dazu, dass YouTube, nein, was sagst du dazu, dass Amazon auch einen YouTube rausbringen
möchte? Ähm, ich find das nicht schlecht. Also, der letzte Versuch, übrigens, erinnert
ihr euch noch, erinnert ihr euch noch, ist ja noch nicht lange her, an YouNow, erinnert
sich da noch jemand dran? Wir kommen, Moment, das gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal kurz zusammen
an. Das müssen wir, Leute, das müssen wir uns jetzt noch mal zusammen kurz angucken.
YouNow, erinnert sich da noch jemand dran? War vor ein paar Monaten mal voll gehypt, kurzzeitig.
YouNow, äh, wupps. So, YouNow. So, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal das Beste. YouNow, jetzt
steht das natürlich da oben nicht mehr da. Ähm, oh, da ist es schon. Also, YouNow wird
geschlossen. YouNow, also, noch vor ein paar Monaten. Nee, warte mal, wie hieß das noch?
Hieß es nicht YouNow? Oh, ich hab's, doch, hieß doch YouNow, oder, was vor ein paar
Monaten voll angesagt war. Oh, fuck, oder verwechsel ich das jetzt gerade? Moment, das
kann sein, dass ich das jetzt verwechsel. Wit-WitMe meine ich, WitMe, nicht YouNow, WitMe, WitMe
meine ich. Ach, so, äh, WitMe, genau. So, und, ähm, das Beste ist, dass WitMe, WitMe
ist down. Das war also quasi vor ein paar Monaten noch der übelste Hype, und jetzt
ist WitMe weg. Ja, Fabian, ich hab das schon vor eineinhalb Monaten oder so mal getwittert
als ich gelesen hab, aber jetzt wollen wir, dass man das mitkriegt. So, und deswegen,
und das war ja eigentlich nur jetzt zur Überleitung, warum ich das, ähm, um dazu was zu sagen,
ob, äh, ob Amazon, also was ich dazu sage, ob Amazon denn jetzt in YouTube aufmacht oder
wie ich das finde, ich finde das gut, denn ich bin nicht mit allem einverstanden, wie
das YouTube handelt. Ob das Amazon besser macht oder schlechter macht, so, das muss
ich dann alles noch zeigen, aber ich glaube, dass Amazon eigentlich so ziemlich der einzige
Laden ist, der sowas machen könnte, was zu YouTube auch nur annähernd konkurrenzfähig
sein kann. Ich trau das sonst eigentlich keinem anderen Laden so richtig zu. So, und, wenn
man davon ausgeht, dass Amazon, quasi ein YouTube, ein FireTube oder wie auch immer,
das bei denen heißen mag, ja, Amazon macht ja bei allem, muss ja bei allem Fire sein,
deswegen wird FireTube hier eigentlich irgendwie mal ein ganz lustiger Name dafür, ähm, dann
geh ich mal von aus, dass da am Endeffekt die Leute auch nur davon profitieren können,
weil, geh mal mal von aus, es gibt zwei Seiten, es gibt zwei große Seiten, wenn man in Zukunft
ausgeblickt, dann ist das jetzt für die Viewer nicht so das große Problem. Ich denke mal,
das wird sich dann schon so etablieren, dass spezielle Sachen eben auf YouTube mehr sind
und auf Amazon andere. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass es quasi, ähm, dann auf YouTube große
Gaming-Channels und auf Amazon große Gaming-Channels, dass da quasi 50% Gaming auf YouTube passiert
und 50% Gaming auf, auf, äh, auf Amazon FireTube oder wie auch immer das heißt, das glaube
ich nicht. Ich geh mal davon aus, dass ich das dann so ein bisschen, dass, dass ich dann
die Creators halt quasi für ihre Sachen das Beste raussuchen lasse. Könnte dann sein,
dass beispielsweise auf YouTube weiterhin dieser ganze Prank und, und, äh, was weiß
ich jetzt hier, Prank, Weinen, Dingsbums, Stumpfsinn läuft und vielleicht noch Gaming
und sonst was. Es könnte natürlich sein, dass ich dann auf Amazon ein bisschen anderer
Content durchsetze, dass es dann vielleicht nicht Gaming ist, dass dann irgendwelche,
äh, sagen wir mal Wissenschafts-Channels oder so sagen, hey, da bietet uns Amazon dann
jetzt das bessere Umfeld für. Könnte ja, könnte ja sein, ne. Also könnte ich mir auch,
könnte ich mir auch wirklich gut vorstellen. Ähm, oder umgedreht, mal gucken. Wovon ich
ausgehe ist, ich mach mal ein bisschen lauter, wovon ich ausgehe ist, dass wenn Amazon sowas
starten wird, dass sie dann auch versuchen werden, dass sie dann auch versuchen werden
ein paar bekannte Leute zu sich zu kriegen. Wobei man sich da fragen muss, ist das sinnvoll?
Das versuchen ja viele, vielleicht macht das Amazon auch ganz anders, wenn ich mir das
so überlege. Also viele, viele Seiten sowas wie, was gibt's da, was gab's denn da alles
hier, ähm, Afrika, äh, äh, ähm, Azubu, äh, Hitbox owned und Gedöns, also viele dieser
Seiten, Hitbox auch im deutschen Raum, haben ja versucht, quasi bekannte Leute zu ihnen
zu kriegen. Wie hießen die Seite, auf der Faker früher gestreamt hat, der LOL-Faker,
war das, war das, ähm, war das Azubu oder war das Afrika? Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es
nicht. Zumindest hatte der wohl mit Sicherheit einen guten Vertrag, äh, hatte aber kaum
Viewer im Vergleich zu dem auf Twitch. Auf Twitch hat er dann gestreamt, mit, mit, wie
viel, weiß ich, wie viele Leute auf Twitch zugeguckt haben, bei ihm irgendwie 100.000
oder so total viel, also richtig massiv viel und, ähm, das heißt, es ist die Frage, ob
es überhaupt sinnvoll ist, wenn man versucht von einer schon bestehenden Plattform, wo
diese Leute ja eben auch ihre Fans haben. Ich mein, in PewDiePie, wenn der jetzt bei
Amazon am Start ist, dann hat er halt, dann nimmt er ja nicht instanz eine komplette Fanbase
mit, die ihn einfach nur auf YouTube verfolgt. Das klappt ja dann nicht. So, ich muss übrigens
erstmal Quests abholen, für, äh, Monster killen, bevor ich hier anfange Monster zu
killen. So, ähm, deswegen glaube ich fast, dass das bessere wäre, Moment, äh, Fabian,
wo steht denn der komische NPC, der ist irgendwo hier oben auf dem Berg, ne? Falls du grad
da bist. Hi, Eax. Ähm, deswegen glaube ich, dass es besser wäre, Amazon würde komplett
drauf scheißen, was, ähm, was es für Leute auf YouTube gibt, sondern sich ihre eigenen
Talente heranzüchten. Gehen wir mal zu Anne. Ich geh mal, ich hoffe mal, eine Quest gibt's
hier oben, Daily Quests. Chimpanzee hat zum Beispiel Hitbox Hard supported. Ich gehe
davon aus, der hauptsächliche Grund wird gewesen sein, weil Hitbox Hard ihn supportet
hat. Weil ansonsten, ansonsten gibt es ja, also wenn man da keine Anreize bekommt von
der jeweiligen Plattform, gibt es ja überhaupt keinen Anlass, auf einer Plattform zu streamen,
wo du prinzipiell weniger Leute erreicht. Das ist ja mal absolut unsinnig, also aus
Content-Creatorsicht. Es ist absolut unsicht, unsinnig, total widersinnig, eine Plattform
zu wählen, zu supporten, wo es weniger Viewer gibt. Das ist total beknackt. So, das heißt,
wenn man das macht, kann das nur daran liegen, dass man eben gute Konditionen mit dem Laden
hat. Oder einem eben, wie man das bei manchen CSGO-Wettseiten gehört hat, an der Laden
gehört. Äh, wie komme ich denn da jetzt überhaupt drauf? Ich stelle es mir da jetzt
irgendwie rauf, das passt schon. Easy, easy life. Ich komme da bestimmt irgendwie rauf.
Hier, so, der da mal hoch. Ich bin Wizard, habe Teleport, da ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ach nee, hier neben geht es ja hoch, sieht man ja. So, das heißt, wenn man mit so einen
Laden dann gute Konditionen hat, dann klar, dass man das da macht. Aber ich glaube, es
ist nicht der richtige Ansatz, sich Talente von anderen schon bestehenden Seiten abzuwärmen.
Ich glaube für Amazon wäre der bessere Ansatz, quasi selbst Talente zu erzeugen bei ihnen,
die bekannt werden. Weil es ist immer schwierig, es ist wirklich schwierig. Mal angenommen,
du hast jetzt, ich sehe es ja im Endeffekt jetzt hier auf Twitch, wobei ich gleich sagen
muss, ich finde das eigentlich gut. Wie komme ich denn hier hoch hier? Ich sehe es ja hier
auf Twitch. Wenn man jetzt eine Fanbase hat, auf einer Seite, wie YouTube, da kannst du
noch so oft was ankündigen oder erwähnen. Es gibt viele Leute, die folgen einfach YouTube,
die folgen dem YouTube-Feed, wer was macht und gucken sich das an. Allerdings, wenn
du dann in einem Video irgendwie sagst, ja, könnte man bei Twitch vorbeigucken oder so,
da denken sie sich, ach so, eigentlich interessiert es mich nicht. Also quasi so komplette Fanbases
zu transferieren von einer zu anderen Plattformen, das geht, also komplett, das geht eigentlich
gar nicht. Daily, jawoll. Easy Daily. Defeat Catreys, 600 Stück. Okay, dann machen wir
jetzt 600 Catreys und danach machen wir Overwatch Viewer Games. Weil Overwatch Viewer Games
direkt vor Black Desert Mob Riot kommt. 600 Catreys dauert aber schon ein paar Minütchen
noch. So, deswegen denke ich, also ich finde es gut, dass Amazon sowas wagen will und
ich glaube Amazon ist der einzige Laden, der YouTube irgendwie Konkurrenz machen könnte
und ich glaube, dass sowohl für die Zuschauer als auch für die Content Creator es nicht
schlecht ist, wenn es mehrere Plattformen gibt. Ich glaube, also ich kenne keinen, ich
will nicht sagen, dass es das nicht gibt, ich kenne eigentlich keinen Content Creator,
der YouTube an sich so vom Handling her und so, also sowohl vom Handling her von der Seite
als auch, wie das so, wie das für die Leute selbst ist, so wirklich geil findet. Du kannst
mit YouTube nicht reden, vielleicht außer du bist PewDiePie, aber erinnert ihr euch
noch daran als, wie hieß er, Ray William Johnson, als der Problem mit YouTube hatte
und sich auch darüber aufgeregt hat, dass er nicht reden kann mit YouTube und es total
schwierig ist, da zu kommunizieren und sowas und ich will auch sagen, der war zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt der größte YouTuber, wenn der nicht mit denen in Kontakt kommen kann. Ja,
hallo. So, also das kenne ich eigentlich keinen, der das geil findet. Und da könnte Amazon
natürlich punkten und für die Zuschauer ist es natürlich auch nicht schlecht, wenn es
ein bisschen Konkurrenz gibt, weil es gibt so viel gutes Zeug, was im Prank und was ist
denn eigentlich gerade so alles im Trend, keine Ahnung, Prank und YouTube Shit Deutschland
total untergeht. Wenn das auf einer anderen Plattform dann besser zur Geltung kommen würde,
finden sich vielleicht auch ganz andere Leute, die dort gucken. Also ich sehe da schon Potenzial
drin. Wie gesagt, ich denke, Amazon ist der einzige Laden, dem ich es zutrauen würde,
sowas auf die Beine zu stellen, weil man sieht das ja an WitMe, selbst WitMe hatte ein bisschen
Hype, aber du machst, du ziehst nicht einfach einen YouTube-Konkurrent auf, ohne Milliarden
im Hintergrund zu haben. Für Technik, für Bewerben, für alles und Amazon hat halt Kohle.
WitMe hatte keine Kohle, außerdem fand ich die WitMe-Seite auch nicht sonderlich tolle.
Und es reicht ja auch nicht einfach, YouTube zu kopieren. Es bringt ja nichts, wenn man
YouTube kopiert und im Endeffekt ein schlechteres YouTube macht, nochmal. Und dann auch ohne
Geld so. Ja, also so sehe ich das mit Amazon und ihrer Videoplattform. Ich weiß nicht,
gibt es dazu schon nähere Details? Ich bash jetzt den Boss erstmal. Gibt es dazu schon
nähere Details, was sie eigentlich machen wollen? Ja, Amazon könnte das, klar könnte
Amazon dadurch punkten, X-Silent LP, dass sie eben die Leute bezahlen, bei ihnen Content
zu machen, aber ich finde, man hat das gesehen bei Azubu und den anderen Dingern, dass es
nicht unbedingt das Beste ist, quasi bestehende Content-Creators zu holen, sondern man sollte
bessere, neue Aushängeschilder für die eigenen Plattformen sich selbst erschaffen. Das Einzige,
wie das funktionieren kann, quasi, nennen wir es mal YouTube-Konkurrent, wenn wir uns
mal Twitch nehmen, heranzutüchten, ohne dass man Milliarden im Hintergrund hat wie Amazon.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass Twitch mittlerweile auch zu Amazon gehört, das heißt Amazon ja
in dem Bereich schon Erfahrung gesammelt hat mittlerweile und jetzt auch kein Unbekannter
mehr ist, geht, wenn man sowas macht wie Gaming, also quasi auf eine Sache zugeschnitten,
wie Twitch und das halt eben ziemlich gut macht, quasi kaum ordentlich Konkurrenz hat
und YouTube jahrelang diesen Zweig links liegen lässt. Das Game Streaming bzw. Stream an sich
war ja jahrelang bei YouTube überhaupt kein Thema und jetzt YouTube Live finde ich im
Vergleich zu Twitch kacke, um ehrlich zu sein. Und das sage ich als hauptsächlich
der YouTube Creator, der auf YouTube jetzt wahrscheinlich anstatt mit 89 Zuschauern
wahrscheinlich mit 890 Zuschauern rumklebsen würde, wenn ich auf YouTube streamen würde.
Aber ich finde Twitch ist einfach die eindeutig bessere Plattform, wenn es um Game Streaming
geht. Das einzige, was Google hat gegenüber Twitch ist der meiner Meinung nach bessere
Player und dass man halt vor und zurück kann, aber das könnten die mit Twitch, das könnten
die bei Twitch garantiert auch so machen, dass du innerhalb von einem Video, also innerhalb
von einem Livestream vor und zurück spulen könntest. Ich gehe davon aus, dass macht
Twitch absichtlich nicht, weil du kannst ja immer noch in die Watts gehen und gucken,
was macht Twitch absichtlich nicht, dass es so einen Charakter von Live hat. Das ist ja
auch eine Sache, wovon Twitch letztendlich lebt, von diesem Live-Gefühl, von dem Chat,
der dabei ist, dass du eben nicht sagst, ich gucke anonym mir jetzt diesen Stream an oder
diesen Content an, sondern ich gucke mir den eben mit vielen Gleichgesinnten, gucke ich
mir jetzt live diesen Content an. Man sieht auch schon, wie halbherzig das auf YouTube
umgesetzt ist. Es gibt einen Live-Chat, allerdings wenn ich zurück spule in YouTube und dann
im Chat was schreibe, quasi auf ein Ereignis, dann wird es im Live-Chat angezeigt, was natürlich
übelst verwirrend ist für einen, der eine halbe Stunde hinten dran ist, auf YouTube
im Player und dann im Chat was schreiben Leute sehen, ist die quasi live zuschauen. Das
ist wieder so eines der 100 Sachen, die an YouTube nicht richtig durchdacht sind.
Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich mich da ein bisschen länger zu auslassen, weil da gibt es echt
viel dazu zu sagen. Ich habe mitbekommen, dass Dezember der beste YouTube-Monat ist.
Dieser Inscope21 und seine Kollegen haben diesen Monat alle täglich in einem Video gemacht
und gegenseitig verlinkt. Denkst du das war pure Gewinnmaximierung? Ich weiß beim Nico
nicht, inwieweit er sich um die Sachen noch selbst kümmert oder da irgendwelche Management
und Agenturen und Sachen dahinter sind, keine Ahnung. Es spielt bestimmt zum Teil mit rein
und ich glaube auch, dass der Nico mittlerweile nicht der gleiche Nico ist wie noch vor ein
paar Jahren. Aber für mich ist der Nico der originale deutsche Lifestyle-Channel. Alle
anderen sind quasi Inscope-Fakes. Und der Nico an sich, da kann man eigentlich überhaupt
nichts Negatives zu sagen. Zumindest den Nico, den ich kenne von vor ein paar Jahren noch.
Über den kannst du echt nichts Negatives sagen. Und selbst wenn es Gewinnmaximierung ist,
was sehr gut sein kann, solange der Konten den Zuschauern gefällt, ist es ja im Prinzip
für beide gut. Kriegen die Leute mehr von ihrem Konten, der ihnen gefällt und man kriegt
mal Kohle. Der Nico guckt hin und wieder noch meine, wie er ich weiß, hat er mir mal geschrieben.
Find ich übrigens geil. Es gibt ja ein paar Leute, die kenn ich noch aus den Zeiten,
wo sie nicht so groß waren. Und beim Nico kann ich mich halt noch dran erinnern, dass
er schon immer Videos in der Richtung machen wollte. Er wusste das bloß nicht. Er wollte
noch nie diese Standard-Call of Duty-Gameplay-Geschichten machen. Er wollte schon immer ein bisschen
abgedrehte Dinge machen. Also was ist abgedrehte Dinge? Wo er sich selbst ein bisschen inszenieren
kann und ein bisschen Blödsinn labern. Das kann er ja auch gut. Ein bisschen lustiges
Zeug machen. Und der war schon ziemlich unglücklich zu der Zeit, wo er gedacht hat, es kommt nur
gut an, wenn man seriöse Call of Duty-Videos macht. Das hat ihm nicht gefallen. Und deswegen
ist es für mich auch so der originale Lifestyle-Channel überhaupt. Der macht nämlich wirklich das,
weil er das gut findet und weil ihm das gefällt. Der macht nicht jetzt irgendwie, ich muss
jetzt krassen Fitness und krassen Lifestyle und sonst was machen. Der wollte das im Prinzip
schon immer machen. Er wusste bloß nicht genau, was es ist. Bis er es dann irgendwann
rausgekriegt hat. Der Nico ist ja kein, ich mache Gameplay-Videos und werde jetzt zum
Fitness-Channel und zum Lifestyle-Channel einfach nur, weil ich weiß, man kann damit
mehr Kohle machen oder bessere Sachen verdienen. Nein, der hat das gemacht, weil er das andere
eigentlich ursprünglich gar nicht mal so wirklich machen wollte. Schon immer was anderes.
Zwingt zum Nico kann ich echt nichts negatives sagen. Zum Danny übrigens auch nicht, auch
wenn den Danny viele nicht mögen. Ich meine, der Content vom Danny ist jetzt nicht unbedingt
das, was ich mir angucke, um neue Synapsen im Gehirn zu bilden. Oder neue Verknüpfungen
im Gehirn zu bilden. Aber da sagt er über ihn als Person X aus und es gefällt vielen
Leuten. Das ist einfach auch Fakt. Oh, Eax, das ist nice. Das ist sehr nice. Easy Drop.
Ja Eax, wie sieht es aus? Bist du gleich dabei? Viewer Games? Overwatch? Machen wir nämlich
ein paar Viewer Games und recken quasi den Blattchat. Wobei die Hälfte wahrscheinlich
besser ist als ich. Und je nachdem, wie fit ich bin, machen wir dann noch Placements
um 0 Uhr. Was haltet ihr von dem Plan? Aber jetzt erstmal hier noch ein bisschen BDO-Quiet.
Ich hab nicht gesagt Platt-Chat. Ich hab gesagt Platt-Chat. Das sagt man bei Overwatch so.
Which chat in Overwatch ist automatisch Platt-Chat. Du weißt ja auch Don't write in chat if you
are not high elo. 2000 plus. Das ist halt Overwatch-Meme gelaber. Catree Bash. Ähm,
ja, um nochmal auf die Sache zurück zu kommen, dass Dezember der erfolgreichste Monat ist.
Also Dezember ist definitiv der Monat, wo man am meisten Kohle machen kann. Das liegt
an mehreren Faktoren. Zum einen, weil die Standard-Essence-Einnahmen im Dezember am
höchsten sind. Und warum sind die Standard-Essence-Einnahmen im Dezember am höchsten? Weil halt alle Werbung
machen wollen im Dezember für ihren Scheiß. Und dementsprechend, wenn alle Werbung machen
wollen zur gleichen Zeit, ist es teurer. So. Und das gleiche gilt natürlich auch für
alle Affiliate-Geschichten und Amazon. Bei Amazon kriegt man zwar nicht mehr, allerdings
kaufen die Leute natürlich im Dezember mehr. Weil Weihnachten ist. Das ist im Prinzip
eigentlich relativ logisch. Ähm, also ich hab kurz vor Weihnachten, also irgendwie
21 oder so mal geguckt. Ich kann das jetzt ja mal revealen. Und wenn ich jetzt, ich kann
es euch nicht mehr genauer auf Offensiv sagen. Allerdings, und ich hab im Dezember auch
viele Videos gemacht, ähm, waren die Einnahmen bei Amazon rein über Adlink. Irgendwo um
wie 600 Euro. So. In dem Dreh. Ich müsste mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist. Wahrscheinlich
dadurch, dass noch nicht alle Sachen von Weihnachten, ähm, durch waren, wahrscheinlich sogar noch
ein bisschen höher. Und das einfach nur durch Amazon, äh, Raffling-Geschichten. Die keinem
was kosten, außer Amazon. Also man sieht schon, dass Dezember da ein krasser Monat ist
in der Richtung. Und das, obwohl ich das ganze Jahr über kaum was gemacht hab. Also ich
kann mich noch an, äh, so irgendwie, weil man so 2013, 14 oder so erinnern, da war das
im Dezember noch ne ganze Ecke mehr. Dezember ist der beste Monat. Oh man, ich, ich Kreisel-Kreinde
war falsch. Hier muss ich hoch. Nee, ich hätte eigentlich da drüben hoch gemusst.
Also nicht mal die Rotation kann er richtig fahren hier. Hab ich noch irgendwas übersehen?
Im Chat jetzt, die letzte Zeit? Falls ich irgendwas überlesen hab, ähm, wenn ihr noch
was wissen wollt, schreibt es einfach nochmal im Chat. Ich guck jetzt nochmal kurz. Mops,
perfesst euch mal. Denkst du nicht, es wäre besser Twitch einfach zu erweitern mit Amazon,
äh, FireTube oder wie auch immer es heißt. Ähm, hm. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so sinnvoll
ist an Twitch jetzt noch mehr anzubauen als diese Game-Streaming-Geschichte, weil Twitch
ist schon sehr eigen. Also Twitch, Twitch, allein schon der Twitch-Chat, ja, die Emo's
und das Rumge-Meme und so, ähm, ist, ist sehr eigen. Und ich glaube, das ist für normale
Viewer zu abgedreht, dass sie das lustig finden. Und das heißt entweder haben normale Viewer
keinen Bock auf Twitch, sich das halt Sachen anzugucken, oder Twitch wird quasi verändert
dafür, dass es den anderen Zuschauern besser gefällt. Und das ist beides was ich eigentlich
kacke finde. Twitch soll so bleiben. Übrigens, ne, noch ein Grund warum ich denke, dass Amazon
da der beste ist in YouTube-Konkurrenz zu machen. Viele Services, nachdem sie übernommen wurden
von größeren Läden, haben sich meiner Ansicht nach zum negativen entwickelt. Und bis auf
ein paar Sachen kann man bei Twitch eigentlich sagen, ist es besser geworden, seit Amazon
Twitch hat. Ich mein, allein schon, dass es jetzt eine Chat-Aufzeichnung in VODs gibt.
Und solche Dinger. Oh, nice, da können wir snipen. Das snipen wir gleich noch. 22.18.
Ey, die sind, es, wisst ihr was, wir machen jetzt den easiest done the snipe of our life,
machen wir jetzt. Alle, alle real life noobs, ja, sind auf irgendwie Silvester-Partys und
sonst was und fühlen sich immer so richtig geil und überlegen, weil es ja also die krassen
Checker sind. Und müssen wir sie natürlich auch bei jeder Gelegenheit erzählen. Und
sonst snipen wir ihnen jetzt geil die Dande weg hier. Die real life noobs, naja. Umso älter
man wird, habe ich das Gefühl, umso weniger Bock hat man auf real life Zeug. Wobei ich
große, wobei ich Ansammlungen oder größere Ansammlungen von vielen Leuten, vor allem
von vielen Leuten, die ich nicht kenne, noch nie gerne, noch nie gemacht hab. Weil da sind
halt meistens immer so die übelsten Spasten dabei, ey. Leute, die man kennt, weiß vor
allem, was Sache ist, ja. Vor allem, wenn es dann irgendwie so eine Veranstaltung ist,
wo jeder dann irgendwelche Bekannten mitbringt und so. Und dann hast du dann Leute, die kennst
nicht und sitzt dann den ganzen Abend mit denen da rum und musst dann irgendwie so voll
auf funny machen oder die versuchen auf lustig und sonst was zu machen und die meisten Leute
sind dann übelst Spaß. Oder ich bin einer und komm einfach mit den meisten Leuten nicht
da. Das kann natürlich auch sein, ja. Katzen sind schon ganz nervös, also meine Katze hat
es überhaupt nicht gejuckt. Meine Katze hat, also Katze, Dings hier unten, die du unten
links siehst, die hat das überhaupt nicht gejuckt, Silvester. Die hat in der Ecke gelegen,
hat gepennt und hat sogar sich auf, das war geil, ich glaube es gibt keine Katze, die
sonst macht, die wollte sogar aus dem Fenster gucken. Ich hab die dann auf den Arm genommen
und da haben wir uns ans Fenster gestellt, runtergeguckt. Manchmal hat sie, manchmal
wollte sie dann weg, als quasi direkt vor dem Fenster irgendwie was in die Luft geflogen
ist so. Aber ansonsten, da fand ich das übelst geil, die hat dann voll interessiert rausgeguckt,
die hat so, was ist das hier oben, die Uhrzeit, boah, geil, was ist hier los. Auf jeden Fall
müssen wir umloggen, 15, 15 müssen wir umlegen. Voller Stereotyp Gamer, ich hab kein Problem
mit. Ohne aber, das ist ja auch immer eine Sache, wo ich denke, ich glaube es ist andersrum,
ich glaube es ist andersrum. Generell glaube ich, ist es bei vielen Sachen, wo man so sagt,
oh voll Stereotyp das oder voll der sowieso, ist es eigentlich andersrum. Leute sind halt
so wie Leute sind und suchen sich deswegen Sachen raus, was am besten zu ihnen passt.
Also ich glaube es ist nicht so, dass man sagen kann, oh scheiß Gamer, alle irgendwie
sozial kriegen sie nichts auf die Reihe, sondern ich glaube Leute, die nicht sonderlich sozial
sind, spielen gerne Games who never post. Aber den ganzen krassen Real Life Silvester
Stelzer, den schnappen wir jetzt die Dande weg. Und dann kaufen wir uns Feuerwerk und
schreiben Get Shrecked an den Himmel. Übrigens, laut YouTube Kommentaren bin ich mittlerweile
voll der Nazi, muss ich mir heute sagen lassen. Vor allem ich, ja. Ich war ja schon alles
ja. Ich hatte mal so paar rechte Spasten da, die mich übelst beleidigt haben, weil ich
Jude bin oder so, haben sie erzählt. Also ich weiß nicht, wie sie auf die Idee gekommen
sind, aber sie waren der Meinung, ich bin Jude und müssen mich jetzt übelst beleidigen.
Erinnert sich vielleicht der Fabian noch dran? Fabian, erinnerst du dich da noch dran? An
Max Flame Account, kennst du den Scheiß noch? Falls du da bist, kannst du dich da noch dran
erinnern? Und das Schlimme war, da gab es erst einen und dann kam immer mehr. Die haben
dann in die Kommentare geschrieben, ich habe gehört, Max ist Jude, deswegen habe ich mich
jetzt hier angemeldet, um ihn irgendwie zu beleidigen. So richtig, richtig hängen geblieben.
So und zumindest jetzt ist wieder was ganz besonderes, jetzt bin ich ganz schlimm, Nazi
und rechts. Warum? Weil ich den Begriff Social Justice Warrior benutzt habe. Und dieser Begriff,
der ist ja schon sowas von Nazi und instant rechts, instant rechtsextrem. Also manche
Leute haben echt nichts besseres zu tun, als sich den ganzen Tag über irgendwas zu empören.
Ich verstehe die Leute nicht, die haben alle kein Leben, die haben alle echt nichts besseres
zu tun einfach irgendwie. Und das witzige ist, wenn man mal in die Wikipedia Seiten
reinguckt zu eben diesem Begriff, sieht man, dass das in vielen Bereichen mittlerweile
eigentlich ein recht gebräuchlicher Ausdruck ist, der quasi abwertend verwendet wird über
Leute, die sich gerne über Themen empören in Richtung multikulturelle Geschichten und
Feminismus und sowas in der Richtung. Und genau darum ging es ja in dem Video auch, nämlich
um schwarze Frauen in der Wehrmacht in Call of Duty. Also, naja. Aber so schnell ist man
laut YouTube Comments schon ein Nazi. Da kann man halt nichts machen. Aber was ich gut finde,
dass die meisten Leute noch ein bisschen was im Kopf haben und gar nicht so eingehen auf
so ein Scheiß. Die ganzen Koreaner kommen jetzt hier online, sehe ich gerade. Ich habe
ja viele koreanische Overwatch-Pros und ein paar koreanische Streamer hier auf Benachrichtigung,
auf Twitch. Irgendwie kommen die ganzen Koreaner jetzt an, weil die Koreaner ist doch schon
neuer seit 8 Stunden oder so. 14 Stunden sind die doch, sind die glaube ich vorne dran.
Ach ja, und der allergrößte Witz bei diesem Video war ja noch, dass ich diesen Begriff
eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht habe. Ich habe das ja nur wiedergegeben, was jemand anderes
in einem Interview gesagt hat. Das war ja noch der größte Witz da dran, das habe ich
noch gar nicht erzählt, was die komplette Diskussion darüber schon wieder total überflüssig
macht. Ne, ne, im Januar sind die Chinesen. Die Koreaner haben glaube ich, oder? Keine
Chinesen. Ich muss umloggen, ich muss dann das Snipe machen. Mal vor nach Korea oder Japan
zu reisen, ja würde ich gern. Aber allein habe ich da keinen Bock drauf. Sollte ich
mal eine Freundin finden, in nächster Zeit wieder, mit der ich es länger aushalte und
die mit mir, dann würde ich auch gerne mit ihr mal nach Island fahren bzw. nach Korea.
Island und Korea sind beide so zwei Sachen, die ich gerne mal hin würde. Allerdings
nicht allein, das wird zu doof. Ach ja, und bitte einen, die sich nicht aufregt, wenn
ich Let's Player in auf Twitter folge. Oh man, es gibt Sachen, das, naja. Und was ist
mit Japan? Also ehrlich gesagt, lieber Korea. Südkorea und Island. Max und Frisur in Korea,
ja. Falsche Richtung. Hoffentlich bin ich nicht zu spät. Es wird geschneibt. 360 Marketplace
Scope. Habt ihr gesehen, was das für eine Dande war? Das war eine ganz normale Un-Enchantete,
oder? Also die hier war das. Keine Un-Enchantete, oder? Habt ihr das gesehen? Ich habe das vergessen
oder nicht richtig realisiert. Welche Let's Playerin bist du da gefolgt? Ich weiß das.
Keine Ahnung. Wer war das? Ich glaube Honeyball oder so. Total bescheuert, hat sich aufgeregt.
Ich würde ja der Let's Playerin nur folgen, dass ich ihr heimlich Messages schreiben kann.
Das ist so abgedreht. Das kann ich mir ohne so voll Cringe gar nicht aussprechen. So Fremdscheme
ist das eigentlich. Bloß dass das nicht Fremdscheme war. Die Velia-Musik ist beste im Hintergrund.
Epische Musik an. Ist ein Spedio so laut genug gewesen? Oder soll Spedio noch ein bisschen
lauter machen? Hast du außer deiner Katze noch andere Haustiere bzw. möchtest du noch
welche haben? Ja ich will mir wieder eine Katze holen. Aus dem Tierheim. Ich war schon
im Tierheim vor einem Monat oder so ungefähr. Und da gibt es ja so viele. Am liebsten würde
ich alle mitnehmen, aber ich muss mich ja zurückhalten. Außerdem muss ich noch warten
bis das Hoftor oben zugemacht ist, dass die Katze nicht durch kann. Meine Letze war einfach
zu alt, die konnte da nicht mehr durch und die hatte auch keinen Bock. Oder aber zwei
Katzen, wenn sie sich halt schon kennen. Dann würde ich auch zwei nehmen, weil das einfach
ein bisschen spannender für die Katze ist. Holst du zwei diesmal? Wenn es sich ergibt,
also ich werde gucken, welche Katzen gerade im Tierheim sind. Genug Platz und für zwei
ist überhaupt kein Problem. Also ich würde bevorzugt zwei nehmen, wenn es halt welche
sind, die schon zusammen gehören und halt zusammen vermittelt werden. Dann würde ich
gerne zwei nehmen, aber ich würde auch eine Einzel nehmen, wenn es halt eine ist, die alleine
sein will. Und ich würde am liebsten wieder eine bisschen ältere Katze nehmen, einfach
weil es ein bisschen getillter ist. Ich meine, ich muss jetzt nicht unbedingt wieder 14-15
sein, weil ich meine, ich habe es jetzt ja bei der letzten Katze gesehen. Das Problem
ist einfach, wenn die Katzen schon so alt sind, das ist halt, man mag ja seine Katze
auch, allerdings wenn Katzen schon 14-15 sind, dann ist halt die Chance, dass sie jetzt nicht
mehr so viel älter werden, halt nicht so klein. Der Google-Rückblick ist besser als
YouTube-Rewind. Was ist denn da so drinnen? Ist das irgendwas Google-bezogenes oder was
so Weltgeschehen-bezogenes? Oh, dann das Snipe. Achtung Leute, alle sind zu Silvesterfeiern
und jetzt lohnt es sich, dass ich da bin und snipen kann. Easy-Snipe. Easy-Easy-Snipe.
Give energy, easy-Snipe. Obwohl, Energy ist zu spät, bis ihr das seht, ist es eh schon
fertig. Achtung, Achtung. Der Result-Flick kommt jetzt hier. Fuck. Scheiße, das wäre
jetzt auch zu geil gewesen, oder? Hätte ich die gesniped, hätte Fabian heute Abend
auch entschaden müssen. Mein zweiter Rechner, wo ich den Chat anzeige, kackt gerade voll
ab. Ähm, ich muss gerade mal an die andere Maus rüber. Was ist denn da los? Äh, Moment,
geht doch. Funktioniert doch alles. Hä? Ist mein Maus-Sharing-Ding abgekackt. Moment.
Mal neu starten. Ich mein, ich muss brauchen zwei Monitors, das ist ganz für den Arsch.
Ah, geht wieder. Gut, alles klar. Ja, blim, blim. Okay. Ja, kriegt sich wieder ein Kack-Programm.
Du, du, du, du, du, du. Du, du, du, du. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du. Ich glaub, Video
kann ich noch einen Ticken lauter machen, ne? Zweiter Rechner von Chat, ne, der zweite Rechner
ist, ähm, Stream-Vorschau und halt mit Chat, Discord, ähm, Donation-Ticker, Follow- und
Hosting-Ticker und wenn ich irgendwas nachgucken will, wo ich halt nicht will, dass man es
ums Stream sieht. Und das ist ja der zweite Rechner, den ich nicht dafür gekauft hab,
das ist der Rechner, den ich hatte vor dem, jetzt. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
So Leute, wir sind jetzt gerade so schön beim Cryanten dabei. Ich würd sagen, ich mach
auch gerade noch mal die Basi-Quests, ist ja auch nicht so weit weg. Ähm, Eax, bist
du schon da? Wegen, wegen Viewer-Games? Er ist grad afk. Ok, wenn der Eax wieder da
ist, fangen wir mit Overwatch-Games ein, aber vorher machen wir noch die, den Daily-Cryant
fertig. So wie ich die kenne, ist er gerade aufgestanden oder so. Ich muss mal kurz Discord
schreiben. So, wir gehen jetzt mal hier zum, wo sind denn die Basis noch mal? Hier neben
irgendwo. Ja, Zen Tower machen wir jetzt, auch gut. Hey Basi, wir machen Basi-Spot. Ähm,
aber Leute, wenn wir, wenn wir Overwatch-Viewer-Games machen, spielen wir ordentlich, ne? Also wir
können vielleicht am Anfang irgendwie so ein paar, paar witzige Fun-Game-Modes machen,
so hier unendlich Ultimate-Charge oder irgendwie sowas, aber danach, ich mein, weil's halt
eben im Rank so selten vorkommt, spielen wir ordentlich Overwatch, ok? Also ordentliche
Team-Coms. Wir können uns höchstens darauf einigen, dass wir Junkrat und Mercy bannen.
Da wäre ich sogar dafür. Wir können, wir können sagen, wir spielen ordentliches, äh,
Competitive Overwatch jetzt zusammen. Allerdings, wir bannen Junkrat und Mercy. Was, Speicher-Lag,
WTF? Was ist da los? Äh, eher, aber reicht's, wenn du das Game neu startest oder? Weil
Speicher-Lag hat ich so extrem ist, dass es nach 10-15 Minuten abkackt, hatte ich in Overwatch
eigentlich noch nie. Ja, Hanzo kannst du gerne picken, wenn's passt. Es, also, es ist
es darf jeder mitspielen. Also, es ist mir egal, ob, äh, Porsche oder GM oder Top 500
oder Overwatch-League-Spieler. Ähm, ist mir wurscht. Allerdings ausgeglichen. Also,
wir müssen gucken, dass wir ungefähr beide Teams immer, Moment, was ist hier los? Dass
wir beide Teams ungefähr ähnlich äh, ausstatten mit Leuten, weil sonst wird das nix. Gehen
wir mal zum Rahm, äh, zum Rahim. Gehen wir zum Rahim. Aber wir spielen gescheit, Leute.
Leute, ich bin schon fertig. So, ich soll Basis bashen, ne?
Basis soll ich bashen, mach ich. So, und jetzt laden wir erstmal den Krempel hier
rein vom Country-Spot, wenn ich wieder in Space hab. Gibt es in BDO einen Server, auf dem
sich viele Deutsche niedergelassen haben, quasi wie Shiva in Final Fantasy XIV? Ich
dachte Odin war der deutsche Server in Final Fantasy. Ähm, es gibt in BDO zwar unterschiedliche
Channels, aber es gibt einen großen Server. Also, das kann jeder mit jedem spielen. D.h.,
am besten ist, dementsprechend gibt es natürlich auch viele deutsche Gilden und ich vermute
mal auch viele Gilden mit, also viele deutsche Gilden mit vielen Spielern. Aber hab ich keine
Ahnung von. Du hast zwar hier Channels, es gab mal unterschiedliche Server, aber das
ist mittlerweile alles ein großer Cluster. Ja, ja, das stimmt, aber seit wann ist das
denn? Seit deinem neuen Monitor, oder wie? Also, wir spielen jetzt, aber bei Viewer Games
machst du mit, oder? Max, programmierst du manchmal einfach irgendwas, einfach weil du
Spaß machst, oder programmierst du sogar Dinge für den Haushalt? Ich mach, klar, weil
es bald Spaß macht. Klar, viele Sachen machen Spaß, die braucht man nicht unbedingt. Klar,
das ist auch das, was man am besten lernt. Also, wenn man sich irgendein Projekt ausdenkt,
wo man sich denkt, ich würde es gerne machen, bzw. ist was, was ich vielleicht anders machen,
das haben wir da jetzt gekriegt, anders machen würde als schon bestehende Software, dann
hat man wenigstens ein Ziel vor Augen, das ist dann einfacher. Ach, du hast wieder Windows
7. Ich glaube, der ist ganz gut. Easy Basi Bash. Ich sehe immer, wie OP der Wizard ist.
Ich kenne ja, ich gucke ja beim Friseur immer zu, wenn er Basis klein ist, ich habe das
Gefühl, der braucht mit dem Ranger länger. Und das, obwohl er viel besser equipped ist,
als Schwimmbiss hat. Das ist auch lustig. Sollte vielleicht jetzt nicht Chat gucken werden,
wenn ich hier mobs rumspringen. Haben wir die Quest fertig? Wo müssen wir jetzt hin?
Direkt hier oben, ok. Huge AoE spells, massive, massive res, massive. Oder wie immer gesagt,
Big Slam.
Wenn ergeblich sind hier Mobs, die ich killen muss. Aber irgendwie...
Sind ja keine Mobs, die ich killen muss. Wo sind denn die Mobs, die ich killen muss?
Vielleicht nicht hier unten, sondern irgendwo hier oben. Gucken wir mal. Wo sind die kleinen
Mobs, die gebashed werden müssen? Hier oben nicht. Wo sind die Mobs? Muss ja hier irgendwo
sein. Ist das richtig? Moment. Oh, ich bin noch hier richtig? Hä? Ich bläste jetzt einfach
mal weiter, Mobs. Wo sind denn die Codraws? Wo sind die Codraws? Hier oben verstellst
es irgendwo. Gucken wir mal hier oben. Sind hier oben welche? Nee. Hey, ich hab neu angefangen
und finde, dass der Riese... Der Riese sieht ziemlich cool aus. Ja, das stimmt. Ich hab
auch einen Riesen. Allerdings ist er nur 56. Und ist mein AFK-Angelheld. Der Berser,
der Bersi, der ist im PvP, ist da ziemlich gut. Also ich bin, wie gesagt, übelster Noob
in dem Game. Aber Bersi ist one on one, das weiß ich, eines der besten Klassen, die es
gibt im BDO. Weil du halt saumäßig viel CC-Attacks hast. Okay, Ejax, sag einfach Bescheid, wenn
du ready bist, dann fangen wir mit Overwatch an. Wo sind die kack Mobs? BDO, please. Also
BDO müssen wir hier unten hin. Moment. Ach hier können wir auch hin? Okay, dann gehen
wir hier hin. Wenn hier nix ist, bashen wir die Mobs da oben. Jetzt müssen wir da hin,
da war aber doch eh auch eben nix. Alter, was ist denn hier los? Was sind denn die Mobs?
Auf YouTube wären jetzt schon die ersten Leute, die sich wieder aufgeregt hätten, weil ich
gesagt habe, Möpse anstatt Mobs. Das ist ja voll abwertend wieder. So, hier ist nix.
Okay, dann gehen wir halt da hin. Manapods verkleiden, das braucht der Wizard halt glücklicherweise
nicht. Bin ich auch froh, dass der Wizard so drankunabhängig ist. Ich glaube, ich habe
vor drei Monaten nur das letzte Mal Tränken gekauft, die habe ich immer noch. Moin Schaskei.
Also bei mir dauert es noch ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden. Moment. Hä? Das war doch gar nicht
der Spot, den wir eben angeklickt haben. Ach nee, da hoch geht es auch noch. Cryton, jawoll.
Das Beste. Alles bashen. Ist das was für Diablo-Spieler?
Also wenn du auf das Mob-Killen von Diablo stehst, dann auf jeden Fall, das mit dem Loot
funktioniert ein bisschen anders als im Diablo. Die Mobs geben hier zum größten Teil keinen
Loot, den du direkt als Ausrüstung verwenden kannst, sondern Gegenstände, die Geld bringen.
Und von den Gegenständen, die Geld bringen, kannst du dir dann wiederum deine Ausrüstung
verbessern, indem du halt craftest oder hier halt gleich das bessere Zeug kaufst. Da ist
sowas zum Bashen. Ähm, guck mal, hier sind so komische Kopras, die muss ich Bashen. Und
wie kriege ich denn die Kopras von Steinen wieder? Wobei, nee. Das sind... Vielleicht,
ich glaube, ich lese den Questtext gleich nochmal. Nö. Eigentlich soll ich nur hier
irgendwas bashen, aber irgendwie ist hier nix. What the fuck, Alter, what the fuck. Basht
mal die Basis da oben jetzt noch. Bam! Bei der Gelegenheit könnte man auch mal unseren
Daily XP Buff ziehen. Daily Exp. Hab ich jedenfalls vorhin überlesen, wo es um YouTube und Amazon
und sowas ging? Oh, Skill-Punkte. Nice, die muss man klar als Abholen. Weil nicht, dass
ich nachher wieder jemand beschwere. Ich gucke nicht in den Chat. Aber ich gucke die ganze
Zeit in den Chat. Aber manchmal kann es passieren, dass ich irgendwas übersehe. Ich finde schon,
das ist was für Diablo-Spieler ist. Ähm. Würdest du sagen, dein YouTube-Channel war
eine der besten Entscheidungen deines Lebens? Meinst du damit anzufangen? Ah, ja. Ja. Also
muss ich gar nicht viel groß drum rumlabern. Kann man glaube ich ganz einfach verantworten.
Auch wenn ich da am Anfang natürlich nicht dran gedacht habe. Das ist ja bei den meisten
Sachen so. Bei den meisten Sachen, die sich im Nachhinein besonders geil rausstellen, hat
man das nicht geplant oder so. Die wenigsten Sachen sind voll durchdacht und kalkuliert.
Außer Hansos Scatter Arrow. Der ist natürlich immer kalkuliert. Okay, ich bin mal wieder
zu dumm, Quest-Objective zu finden. Ah, so ist das halt bei mir, ne?
Wir wechseln. Wir wechseln das einfach mal in den Channel. Wahrscheinlich sind hier
alle Mops schon tot. Aber wenn du was suchst, wie Diablo-Spiel Pass of Exile. Also wenn
es hier vor allem um diesen Nude-Aspekt dabei geht, dann Spiel Pass of Exile. Wenn es hier
ums Mops-Passion geht und wenn es eher Richtung MMO gehen soll, dann ist BDO das beste, was
du zurzeit machen kannst. Aber wenn es hier um Loot und Monster-Kloppen geht, also das
Loot wie Diablo, dann eindeutig Pass of Exile. Das ist das beste, was es gibt in der Richtung.
Seit Jahren schon. Du brauchst sinnlose, okay, die sind um den Tempel rum. Dann ist ja mal
die Anzeige der Spots wieder richtig geil. BDO-Quests. Da, da ist eine. Bashen. Das kleine
Kackzeug. Guck mal, hier sind alte BDO-A. Die Anzeige von den Quest-Objectives ist ja
mal wieder sowas von fail. Ich meine, hier sind ganz viele, ja. Und an den Stellen. Guck
mal, wo ich bin. Hier bin ich. Und angeblich da, da, da und da ist die Quest. Well played
BDO. Beziehungsweise Pearl Abyss Kakao. Dann da. So, Quest fertig. Easy. Oh Mann, ist das
bescheuert gewesen. Ich bin genau da gewesen, wo das Licht hingeautorunnt ist. Sogar drei
verschiedenen Spots. Ups. Oh, da gibt es Combat Points. Okay, ich muss Basis bashen. Easy.
Dafür bin ich eigentlich gekommen zum Basis-Baschen. Moment, das sind auch Basis, die sehen gar
nicht so aus. Na, wenn BDO das meint, dass das Basis sind. Du spielst jetzt einfach mal
alles an, was dir über den Weg läuft. Das kann nicht schaden. Also, sich ein bisschen
umzugucken, weil man gerade so kein Main-Game hat, ist immer gut. Ich mache es anders.
Ich gucke mir die Games an und habe dann immer das Gefühl, ich finde 90 Prozent scheiße
und fange dann erst gar nicht mit an zu spielen. Das ist auch nicht der beste Ansatz. Musik
intensifies. So Leute, sobald ich die Basis kaputt habe, loggen wir auf Overwatch um.
Dann sind wir nämlich auch gut eingespielt, wenn die neue Season losgeht. Der Eaxe ist
noch off. Eaxe, bist du off? XQC online spielt gerade Minecraft. Weißt du, so schlimm ist
es schon um die Overwatch Pros, wenn Overwatch nicht on ist, also beziehungsweise die Season-Pause
ist. Man merkt auch, dass es auf 24 Uhr zugeht. Leute werden weniger. Bashing.
Habt ihr eigentlich was im Steam Winter Sale gekauft? Also, was ich gekauft
habe, habt ihr ja gesehen. Hab ich ja im Stream, haben uns ja angeguckt, was es so gibt. Habt
ihr euch irgendwas gekauft? Und wenn ja, was? Das ist voll uneffektiv, ich brauche mehr
Basis. Bayonetta, okay. Stimmt, das gibt es jetzt auch auf dem PC, ne? Spell Force 3,
okay. Kann man das jetzt spielen mittlerweile? Bei Release war das ja in fragwürdigem Zustand.
BR4 Premium, okay. BR4 ist zu einem richtig guten Game geworden jetzt. Nach der ganzen
Zeit. Da sieht man mal, dass man eben auch aus, sagen wir mal, Fails am Anfang, wenn
man sich darum kümmert und dann noch ein bisschen Zeit rein steckt und Leute dran setzt, denen
das nicht komplett egal ist, immer noch ein gutes Game draus machen kann. Hat man ja auch
an Rainbow Six gesehen. Rainbow Six am Anfang, richtiger Fail vor allem, überhaupt nicht
gut angekommen. Und jetzt, verkauft, millionenfach verkauft und die Leute finden es auch geil.
Also, wenn man nicht einfach durch was raushaut und danach den Support einstellt und sich
nicht mehr darum kümmert, kann man auch, wenn es am Anfang nicht so geil ist, noch was
Geiles draus machen. Prey und Alex. Das neue Prey wollte ich auch noch spielen. Es gibt
viele Sachen dieses Jahr, die ich noch spielen wollte. Auch mal zur Abwechslung wieder das
neue Assassin's Creed, was ja wirklich gut sein soll. Ich hätte im Leben nicht dran
gedacht, dass ich noch mal, quasi, mich drauf freue, einen Assassin's Creed zu spielen.
Für mich ist der Ezio ja immer noch der eins schwere Assassin's Creed Held. Ezio
ist der. Ezio Auditore. Da, da Firenze oder so. Da Firenze. Wieso ist deine Waffe nicht
ultimate? Ist sie. Guck, da. Endlich ordentlich viele Basis hier.
Der Eaxe ist wieder da. Okay. Jetzt muss er bloß noch wieder ins Stream kommen, dann
können wir zur Overwatch wechseln. Das ist aber gut, dann habe ich auch die Quest fertig.
Top. Perfekt. Habe ich meinen schönen Daily-Cryant-Exp-Contribution-Points gemacht. Also, nur mal um sicher zu gehen,
dass wir jetzt auch gleich, wenn wir Viewer-Games machen, Overwatch genug Leute haben. Wer würde
mitmachen? Oder wer will mitmachen? Weil wenn wir kein Game voll kriegen, dann werde ich
bis die Season anfängt noch weitercryingen. Werden wir mit Overwatch spielen. Aber wohlgemerkt
ordentlich Overwatch. Also mit ordentlicher Comp. Das Einzige, was wir machen können,
ist, wir können Junkrat und Mercy rausbauen. Was mich auch interessieren wird, schreibt
nochmal bitte euren Rang dabei, weil ich so ungefähr sehe, wie die Verteilung ist. So,
jetzt abgeben. Fertig. Auf kleiner Vizarte. Vizarde. Wegfindung. Beste. Mick ist erforderlich,
es wäre ganz gut. Muss aber nicht die beste Quali sein. Aber Mick wäre schon nicht schlecht.
Wir wollen das hier ordentlich spielen. Overwatch ist einfach Teamwork-Game. Es ist so ein riesen
Unterschied. Das werdet ihr jetzt auch hier gleich sehen. Es ist ein riesen Unterschied,
ob man Overwatch im Rank spielt oder jetzt sogar hier, wo wir noch nie zusammen gespielt
haben, wenn alle Leute wenigstens an einem Schrank ziehen wollen. Eax, bist du wieder
da? Es fehlen immer noch Skillpoints.
Okay, Eax, probieren wir es mal aus jetzt. Probieren wir es mal aus. Okay, ich ändere
das Gamer auf Overwatch. Das Mob-Pack mache ich noch kaputt. Dann locken wir um. Also
Leute, kriegen wir insgesamt, wie viel brauchen wir? 12, 10. Kriegen wir 10 Leute zusammen,
die mit spielen wollen, ja? Und so wie ich das sehe, so in dem Dreh Gold bis Diamond
wahrscheinlich die meisten. Weil wir auch ein paar Master-Spieler haben. Okay, machen
wir. Dann locken wir um. Das Game ändern. Overwatch. So hat sich das Game geändert.
Immer noch nicht. Ich glaube, Twitch braucht einfach eine Weile, bis sich das Game ändert.
Es ist einfach nicht so schnell. So, hat es jetzt geswitcht auf Overwatch? Oder bugged
es wieder? Äh. Capture es mal wieder auf Overwatch, richtig? Hammer gleich. Okay,
Game Capture. Overwatch. Jawoll, da ist es. Gut, machen wir Custom Game auf. In der Hoffnung,
dass es jetzt umgestellt hat auf Overwatch. Ja, hat umgestellt auf Overwatch. Perfekt.
Bei meinem Handy steht immer noch IRL. IRL sollte es schon längst nach BDO gewechselt
haben und jetzt nach, jetzt denke ich es hier nach Overwatch. Aber man weiß ja nicht so
genau, was da. Gut, wie geht denn das? Mir fällt auf, ich hab jetzt seit Monaten kein
Custom Game aufgemacht. Play. Game Browser. Create. Oder geht das noch irgendwie anders?
Müssen wir mal schauen, nicht? Ja, zwei Stunden bis zur nächsten Season. Nee, kann
er nur da drüber gehen. So, Settings lassen wir Standard. Heroes. Das Einzige, was wir,
was wir mal verbieten, ist Mercy. Da hab ich echt keinen Bock drauf. Obbei eigentlich
müssen wir das nicht verbieten. Ich sag das einfach. Keine Mercy. Easy. Test, Test. In-Game
Sound geht auch. So Leute, ich stell das jetzt hier auf. Ach, man kann das über den Nightbot
ändern. Das ist gut, das ist sehr nice. Also, wir machen jetzt hier Max Führer Games.
Ach, Moment. Settings. Das kann man bestimmt noch in Competitive umstellen. Hab das noch
nie gemacht mit dem neuen Menü. Standard 6x6. Competitive. Ja. So, also das Game, das heißt
jetzt Max Führer Games. Und ich stell das jetzt ein auf, dass jeder joinen kann. Geht
das so? Mach ich das richtig? Ja. Bäm. Erster schon am Start. Moment. Anubis? Nein, nein,
nein. Wir fangen nicht mit ner Kackmap an. Geh weg. Wir fangen an mit, mit welcher Map
wollen wir anfangen Leute? Komm, King's Roar Winter. King's Roar ist gute Map. Eaxe
hier. Options, Sound, Voice. Hallo? Hallo, hallo? Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Leute, sollte ich euch, sagt ihr irgendwas? Sollte ich euch jetzt hören? Okay, ich versuch
mal mein Voice Chat irgendwie zum Laufen zu kriegen, das spackt. Hallo, hallo? Ah, funktioniert.
Sehr gut. Hallo? Thomas? Thomas? Also eh, ich höre nicht, das ist schon mal gut, das
weiß ich, prinzipiell funktioniert es. Alles klar. Ja, das ist, das ist schlecht. Ich mein,
es war Weihnachten, hätte es ja mal langsam, aber sicher mal eins besorgen können. Leute,
ich würde sagen, bei irgendeinem Musikshop für Schlagzeug oder so. Nee, es gibt für
Schlagzeug so Switches zum irgendwelche Teile an und ausschalten, die kann man dann, kann
man stimmend an den PC anschließen. So Leute, also wir brauchen noch ein paar, die mitspielen,
sonst müssen wir wieder Mobcrime machen. Also wer noch will, auf gehts. Ich muss jetzt
mal gucken, was wir hier für Ränge haben, so ungefähr. Gold? Diamond? Okay. Smurf?
Gut, ich war. Platin? Na, gucken wir mal nicht, dass es zu unverwehrt. Diamond? Plat, okay.
Und? Auch wahrscheinlich Smurf oder so, nee. Kein mit dem Level eher nicht. Oder eher
mit dem Level eigentlich auch nicht. Also ich werde es jetzt erstmal so lassen, einfach
so wie die Leute reingekommen sind. Wenn es jetzt total unbalanced ist, dann fliegt es
wieder raus. Und wir machen jetzt mal die epische Musik aus. Und ich glaube, ich mach meine
Push-to-Talk-Activation ein bisschen niedriger. Geht das überhaupt? Ja, glaube ich gar nicht.
War gut. Da nicht. So, einen brauchen wir noch. Mach ich die Musik wieder an, bis einer drin
ist. Gibt es eigentlich einen Community-Discord oder TS? Nee, gibt es noch nicht. Das will
ich seit Monaten schon machen. Seit Monaten. Aber irgendwie, kriege ich das nicht gebacken.
Ich habe zwar schon einen Discord erstellt, schon ewig her. Aber noch nichts großartig
eingerichtet. Außer halt einen Channel, wo man Videos aufnehmen kann. Also die letzten
paar Videos, die ich mit anderen Leuten aufgenommen habe, haben wir alle über Discord aufgenommen.
Also Leute, wie gesagt, einer fehlt noch. Dann können wir anfangen. Also wer noch mitspielen
will? Ich meine, es haben immerhin vorhin irgendwie 20 Leute oder so. Nee, 12. 17 Leute
Custom-Games gewonnen. Also, muss weiter. 6 vs. 5. Das könnte man theoretisch machen,
wenn wir die besseren Leute haben. Dann spielen wir 5 gegen... Wenn wir die besseren Leute
haben, spielen wir 5 gegen 6. Ich glaube, wir haben die besseren Leute. Wollen wir 6
gegen 5 spielen? Wir haben die besseren Leute laut Stats. Sagt keiner was. Also wir müssen
uns natürlich umdrehen. Max, kann man gleich noch rein? Du kannst jetzt rein. Ein Platz
ist noch frei. Es ist voll. Okay, easy. Auf geht's. So, Musik ausmachen. Ich glaube,
die Lautstärke ist gut. Ich glaube, ich kann sogar Overwatch Tickenleiser machen. So,
du bist Mercy, man. Na ja. Da haben wir jetzt echt Zeit. Max, ach, check, check, check,
check. Max, ach, Chat-Overlay ist ja noch an. Ja, ja, ja. Moment, mach ich weg. Jetzt
ist es weg. So, äh, jetzt. Erste Runde. Auf dem Platt haben wir die deutlich besseren
Leute. Ein bisschen Warmspiel für neue Season. Auf geht's. Ich hoffe, die geht auch direkt
24 Uhr los. Du besitzt nicht mehr das Game. Also Overwatch ist ein richtig, richtig geiles
Game. Das einzige Problem ist, dass der Rank Mode einfach so komplett verschissen ist.
Hanzo am Start. Moment, hört mich überhaupt jemand? Hallo? Hallo, hallo? Ach, nice. Aber
keiner was sagt. Ich glaube, die kommen links rum.
Die haben eine Widow unten, Hanzo. Oh, nice, Schild. Ey, komm, geht doch eigentlich. Jetzt
müssen wir mal ein bisschen draufdrücken hier. Der Hanzo springt sich da ein ab. Welche
Grafikanstelle verwendest du? Low, Low. Achtung, Achtung jetzt. Der wird jetzt, der wird geregt.
Ich brauche Heal. Oh, nice, Schild. Ich spiele auf Low-Grafics. Okay, ich glaube, die Teams
sind nicht ganz fair. Da müssen wir nach der Runde was machen. Aber die Zarya ist auf
Deck, das muss man sagen. Hinter uns. Oh, Shrecked.
Max schon mal Overwatch an der Konsole gespielt? Ja, beim Kaboom habe ich schon mal Overwatch
an der Konsole gespielt. Und ich habe festgestellt, dass Torb das OPste aller Zeiten ist auf der
Konsole. Back. Just come back. Komm, komm zurück. Jetzt müssen wir auf unseren Reinhardt
warten. Wir müssen auf den Reinhardt warten. Oh, die Zarya ist übelst overextendert. Meine
Hooks sind ja die besten. Ich meine, wie oft hat der Hanzo eigentlich
alt hier? Okay, back. Ich glaube, der Reaper ist oben. Lass weiter, zurück, zurück. Wir
müssen auf unseren Tank warten. Nicht sterben, nicht sterben. Okay, Reinhardt vor und Ruff.
Huge. Merci. Ja. Zurück. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Zurück. Der Reaper, der sieht so aus, als geht er rechts rum und flankt. Könnt
ich mir gut vorstellen. Müssen wir gleich aufpassen. Ihr seid übelst leise. Ich muss
mal gucken, wie ich euch lauter kriege. Oh, oh.
Danke für die Waffe. Perfekt. Ah. Zurück. Super grob. Ja, das ist, auf der Waffe ist
relativ schwierig zu spectaten, wenn man das nicht spielt. Ja, regroupen. Regroupen und
dann direkt drauf. Haben wir eine Mei ult? Ja, wir können direkt mit der Mei ult, können
wir die schön nochmal vor dem Spot. Rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf.
Na ja, ausprobiert. Die Spieler zwar was anderes, was haben die hier?
Einen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Null. Fail.
Fail!
Hahaha!
Wo ist denn der Soldier? Oder der Hanzo?
Oh Gott!
Hab ich die gefressen? Hab ich sie gefressen?
Jawoll!
Zarya gefressen, so muss das sein.
420 pro gameplay, naja, naja.
So, volle Pole drauf, in your face.
Ähm, hast du eventuell Tipps für Junkrat? Nein.
Außer, dass Junkrat zur Zeit eines der nervigsten europäischen Helden ist im ganzen Game.
Also Junkrat spielen aktuell ist keine schlechte Idee.
Aber ich finde den Held, also mir macht der Held keinen Spaß zu spielen, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Es macht auch keinen Spaß gegen ihn zu spielen.
Und ich finde Junkrats einfach nur dumm, wie er zur Zeit ist.
Aber halt, übelst, übelst gut, ja.
Eigentlich spiele ich am liebsten Support und wenn es danach geht, Lucian und Ana.
Leider ist Ana gerade nicht so wirklich gut dabei.
Jetzt spielen die Junkrat, kann gut sein.
Also es wäre sinnvoll für die Junkrat zu spielen, auf jeden Fall.
Wobei wir ganz gut direkt auf den Spot können.
Ich meine, wir haben hier zwei Dive-Tanks plus ein Genji, also das geht schon.
Übrigens Leute, wir können Deutsch reden, weil es sind alle Deutsch.
Ich hoffe, dass da einer mitkommt.
Nein, fuck!
Fuck, ich hätte beinahe eine Bombe gehabt.
Ah, wo sind denn alle?
Alle daunen.
Ich spiele ja keinen Junkrat.
Ich hätte es auch gewundert, dass sie keinen Junkrat spielen hätte, hätte ich gedacht.
Haha!
Leute, Leute!
Wo sind denn alle hin, auf einmal?
Ich glaube, die Junkraten sind hier.
III
Rotock, links.
Left, sein.
Ich dachte, du hast das Gamely installiert.
Done, hatte ich, hatte ich.
cal Do yesterday
Das letzte Mal wird er gespielt
Above
Woah
Hanzo
Das Game sieht unbalanced aus
Ich fand im Attack ging es eigentlich jetzt schon
Danach mussten wir ein bisschen durchswitchen
Bam
Jetzt wird schon mal ein bisschen durch
Nein nein das ist noch nicht Season 8
Season 8 geht erst in einer Stunde los
Da hat er gelasert
Egal
Kann ich jetzt? Weiß jemand, wenn ich jetzt Leafgame mache, kommen wir dann wieder in die Lobby?
Achso, kommen wir in die Lobby
So, wen haben wir denn hier am Start?
Den ersten Mal, move, zack
Kann er mitmachen
So, ähm, wie movet man denn jetzt Leute?
Wen moveen wir jetzt mal hier? Divine war ganz gut
Wir müssen das mal ein bisschen ausbalancen
Ähm, ich glaube
Wir switchen mal
So, was für eine Map wollen wir jetzt spielen? Wir spielen jetzt Maps
Wir spielen jetzt Attacke und Intuzipi, Hanamura, wirklich, wollen wir wirklich Hanamura spielen, ja?
Okay, spielen wir Hanamura
2Cp in 2k 17, 2k 17, 2k 18, lol
So, wen haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Diamond
Ja, dann switchen wir mal, wir switchen einen von uns
Switchen wir mal Divine, switchen wir mal mit ihm
Und
Ansonsten war der Rest eigentlich Diamond, das müsste eigentlich
Probieren wir es auch so
Also direkt passend zum neuen Jahr, der neue Season, also wenn das, wenn das sich deckt mit der Zeit, wo wir eben nachgeguckt haben
Ich würde schon sagen, da stand doch vorhin 2 Stunden, da war es 22 Uhr, wo wir geguckt haben
21, das müsste eigentlich genau, genau losgehen um 24 Uhr
Wicked scheint echt auf Mei zu stehen in Defense, haben wir irgendwas, was ordentlich bisschen bisschen Damage macht?
So richtig, wir haben Genji, der gerne abgehen, na klar wir haben Xen, der macht auch Damage, aber die Mei muss halt rechte Klicks treffen, gucken wir mal
Schauen wir mal, wie das läuft
Crouch spam, wie die Pros
Klicks alle weg genau
Wir sind gut, oder?
Aizuu
Gucken wir mal, wo die Fahrer lang kommt
Ding Ding Ding Ding Ding Ding Ding, wo sind die Fahrer?
Jetzt ist keiner mit gepusht, lol
Und ich konnte kein Schild mehr setzen, fuck
Wir haben ne Mercy, egal, egal, die kriegen wir so auf den Sack gerade
Nice, nice
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Alle, immer mein
Bongos am Start
So, komm mit rein
Ok, das Twitchen hat alleine nicht allzu viel gebracht, jetzt müssen wir glaube ich noch ein bisschen anders durchwechseln
Wie spricht man einen Twitch-Namen aus, kannst du Wupplos sagen
Einmal Lucio, immer Lucio
Im Herz zumindest, Herz93
Ich mag eigentlich alle Supports, bis auf Mercy, den musst du halt spielen
Ich mag auch alle Tanks, bloß mit DPS bin ich jetzt erst nicht so gut, außerdem gefallen mir Genji und Tracer vom Playstyle her gar nicht
Ist einfach nicht meins
Dummfist auch nicht
Ich bin eigentlich eher Off-Tank-Support-Main
Aber Lucio bester
Ich hoffe es kommt ein Patch, der Mercy mal wieder auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückholt
Und das wieder Lucio, Ana, Lucio, Ana bester Support
Vor allem Ana, Ana ist wenigstens eine der Helden in dem Spiel, wo es noch einen Unterschied macht, ob du es gut spielst oder nicht
Nicht so wie bei Mercy, wo das, naja, ich will nicht sagen, dass es keinen Unterschied macht
Aber es ist halt, naja, Mercy halt
Ist immer nur Schützenpacken
Jo, jo
E-Junkrat
Zu spät
We wait for Genji, then go
Das war so nicht geplant glaube ich
Eine gute Attacke, rekt
Das war gut, jetzt haben sie sich auf mich konzentriert, es war zwar nicht so geplant, aber rekt
Schreckt
Ana Damage Buff war unnötig, ja finde ich auch
Das Problem ist ja einfach, dass Mercy so OP ist
Wir sind schneller wieder da
Volle Pulle
Was geht mit der Widow ab ey, die will es aber wissen
Die Widow will es echt wissen
Das, was wir uns jetzt angucken
Ein wenig einseitig
Ich glaube wir müssen noch mal ein bisschen Spieler switchen
Das war jetzt auch nicht so balanced
Das ist schwierig, das ist schwierig, wenn man Leute quasi aus allen
Aus allen Ratings dabei hat
Das ist schwierig, echt schwierig
Also wenn noch jemand mitspielen will
Dann gucken wir, dass wir das jetzt mal ordentlich verteilen
Ana rage quitten, ja würde ich ja auch
Aber es ist verdammt schwierig das fair hinzukriegen
Ich habe jetzt extra schon geguckt, dass wir noch einen Master rüber switchen
Und wir quasi einen Gold zu uns nehmen
Was es dann vom Rang her ungefähr gleich macht
Aber es hat nicht gereicht
So Balanced Blizzard bestimmt noch seine competitive Games
Das Gefühl habe ich auch
Wir haben Gold Gold Plat Diamond glaube ich
Was für eine Map wollen wir
Was war Xilent nochmal
Ja gut, der war Season 3 auch Highmaster
Ich schätze eine Map aus
Eichenwalde
Moment
Ich muss mal wieder auswählen
Eichenwald
So
Es ist wirklich saumäßig schwierig das zu balancen
Wir haben halt alles dabei
Es ist halt im Prinzip von Gold bis Top 500
Dachte du hast Overwatch deinstalliert
Hatte ich auch ja
Hi Kios
Sprechen wir das überhaupt so aus Kios?
So wie der Laden der Zeugs verkauft
Wie geht es Kats FPS ist nicht mehr unter uns
Wenn du genau was wissen willst kannst du bei mir auf YouTube das letzte Video angucken aus dem Garten
Easy Clap
Ich habe das Gefühl meine Voice Activation funktioniert überhaupt nicht richtig
Was Kios
Kios
Verstehe
Versteht ihr den Voice Chat Ingame? Für mich ist der übelst leise
Und ich weiß nicht so genau warum
Hallo, heal please
Nope
Fuck
Du bist all ich bin leise
Also von meinem Voice ist top
Es leuchtet blau
Also Ingame Sound müsste eigentlich okay sein und ich müsste okay sein oder?
Das einzige was ein bisschen leise ist bei mir ist der Voice von den Leuten
Kann mich nicht umdrehen
Vielleicht wenn ich mich umdrehe
Vielleicht gleich
Ingame ist zu leise okay Ingame kann ich gleich lauter machen
Okay
Achtung Leute
Ich gucke mal ob ich etwas lauter machen kann
Okay Game müsste jetzt lauter sein
Besser
Moment
Der hat Earth Shatter, der hat garantiert Earth Shatter
Das war ein nicer Charge
Ist der Soldier tot?
Fuck
Übelst überforderung pur gerade alles Reinhard
Ja Reinhard ist halt nicht so unbedingt jetzt beim Aussehen gestellt
Fuck
Krasser Shatter
Ist jetzt Ingame ordentlich von der Lautstärke her
Ist Ingame Sound okay
Ja ist okay
Fuh
Weil das ziemlich gut ist da kann der Soldier immer so viel reißen
Fuck
Alter recken sie uns aber
10% mehr ich weiß nicht was mit meiner Soundcloud Stärke heute los ist
Okay
Watt
Soll ich mich verarschen
Kill mich please
One fight
Don't die just fight nochmal
Achtung
Hilfe
Also mehr ging gerade echt nicht
Nice
23 51 Overwatch ja ja so muss das sein
Fuck dich Reinhard
C9
Hab ich irgendwie gerade meine
Das ist aber übelst kaputt bei dir das ist ganz merkwürdig
Grip
Vor allem in defense jetzt
No hab ich öberst
Es oder
da ist er wieder
klar
kommt der Hanzo
Skatter
wieso machst du deine Boxen nicht auf?
ich weiß nicht, ich mach die Winterboxen immer auf
Hanzo
Skatter
das wirst du ja überrannt
ich kann aber meine Boxen gleich aufmachen
ich muss kurz nach der Runde dann mal 5 Minuten AFK und dann
so weit 24 Uhr und so
Nope
Regroup
ich versteck mich bei Jon
mein Gott, Volker-Mord
schreckt
der Hanzo
Skatter
Nope
ich kann ja nicht alleine vor
Alter, mach doch mal ein bisschen Damage auf den McCree
der McCree muss sterben
ausgekaubeut
das war
Pre-Ulted
die Kravathans schon fast
nein, da kann man sie nicht dahinter verstecken
uns fehlt das Schild
habe ich das Gefühl, es fehlt so ein bisschen die Stabilität
Alter
die Vols aber, wie sie jetzt
Fuck, ich kann jetzt nicht switchen, das ist gacke
Simple Geometry
Sieh nahe
So, das ist noch nicht neue Season, nein, nein, das ist Führer Games, hier neue Season ist jetzt gleich
so
ok, nice, da haben wir jetzt Schluss mit Führer Games und dann machen wir
Moment, Minuten, seh ich das richtig
oder Sekunden
oder dauert die neue Season noch
die neue Season dauert noch
da fuck, ich bleib mal kurz afk, gleich Führer
so Leute, ich wünsche euch alles Gute für 2018
übertreibt sie mit irgendwelchen Vorsätzen nicht
weil die halten ihr wahrscheinlich eh nicht ein
mein Mikro, mein, mein, RZ Spack, Moment
so, jetzt ist besser
ja, übertreibt sie mit den Vorsätzen nicht
und werde Top 500, easy
alles Gute Leute
so, mein Problem ist jetzt, ich dachte es geht jetzt die neue Season los, aber sie geht gar nicht los, perfekt
das heißt, wir können es ja noch mal probieren
wollen wir noch ein paar Games machen zusammen, also ich mein wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit, ne
aber Placements mach ich erst morgen
also wenn das erst um 1 Uhr nachts los geht, ist mir das zu spät heute
da spielen wir ja bis 4 Uhr nachts oder 5 Uhr
ist es vielleicht noch offen
ist es ein Fake Max Viewer Game
ich glaub das ist ein Fake Max Viewer Game gewesen
ok, dann machen wir jetzt ein LUL in 2k18
also, verscheiden wir Leute LUL in 2k18
auf gehts
kommen wir einfach noch ein paar Matches zusammen kriegen
wenn wir noch ein paar Matches zusammen kriegen
dann spielen wir noch ne Runde
Rx anschreiben, äh Rx bist du noch im Stream?
leider hat mich die neue Season gebaitet
ich dachte die geht jetzt los
der Valverde ist auch am Start, nice
hört ihrs im Hintergrund übrigens?
ich mach mal kurz Leute, ich mach mal Fenster auf
ziehen wir uns mal die volle Silvester Experience 2k18 rein
da gehts ab
so, genug Real Life, fertig
hat sich ausgerelifed
das reicht jetzt auch für Real Life heute
ja, ich find auch genug real
Feuerwerk in 2k18
jetzt drehen sie aber richtig auf da draußen
das geht nicht Leute, das ist nicht möglich
ich mach jetzt Rollarten runter
so viel Real Life, Feuerwerk und ne, das geht nicht
wir brauchen jetzt irgendwie passende Musik
was macht man da?
was 99 Übels angesagt hat, war natürlich Final Countdown
das war 99 der Shit, also es ist zwar schon viel älter
aber 99 zu 2000, ey, rauf und runter gelaufen
das muss sein
das muss echt sein
50 Milliarden
so, einer fehlt noch
jetzt fang ich auch schon mit XD an
also, Übels ausrasten wir dabei
was bei dir zündet eine Autos an?
wenn man wirklich eine Autos anzündet, würde ich jetzt mal schon die Polizei rufen
ehrlich gesagt
oh, jetzt haben wir den ultra krassen GM Genji Main als Gegner
ok, auf gehts, go go
ahja Leute, immer noch keine Mercy, ne?
egal, egal, Posse, wurscht
äh, Defend
ja, ja, ja, das mach ich, mach ich
auch geil, ne? das ist Blizzard Logik
ein Stream von Max und eben bei Football, besten Silvester
Football, ok
das muss ja zur Musik passen
was ist das denn?
BTF, ey
die haben uns zerrissen, schreckt
kommen wir nochmal drauf?
der Winston, Winston Main kommt jetzt
äh, suche Gegner
die kann sich ja komplett voll leechen
das war so nicht geplant
jetzt haben wir kein Schild, fuhu, kein richtiges Schild
hat er Gears, Shattered?
nice
gucken, wo die lang kommen
perfekt
wo ist denn der Reaper?
das war auch hier ein bisschen wasted und gerade
bin ich froh, dass wir ohne Mercy spielen
das ist einfach der Shit
können wir gleich gehen?
oh, es lieb
Retrub
Tracer ist direkt auf Main
nein, nein, nein, nein Reinhard
was in beiden Teams?
ich hab gleich Ulti, ich kann aber noch nicht rein
dafuck
E-Ax, E-Ax, mach so platt
das Schlimme ist noch zuzuschauen, ja das stimmt
ne, nix mehr
die sind aber echt tough, die sind aber echt geil auf mich
die sind echt mega geil auf mich
was haben wir denn, wir haben eine D.Va, wir haben eine Ana
das kann ganz gut klappen jetzt
das Problem, dass ich Zarya schon wieder einmal ewig nicht gespielt habe
ein bisschen style
oh, oh, oh
das hat uns jetzt zerrissen
aber es ist relativ balanced, 29 Sekunden ist okay
was haben wir denn jetzt gescheit, ich würde ja normalerweise sagen Winston
das ist ganz okay, total gemischt von den Ranks
diesmal ist wirklich, das hast du ja selten, von Bronze bis Top 500, alles dabei
E-Ax ist Top 500
also unsere Ana
achja Meurer Orbs geben ja keinen Charge habe ich ja vergessen
auf Jump
wo ist die fucking Widow da oben
da darfst du nicht zu lange rumfackeln
ich kann da nicht als einziger rein, das geht noch nicht
jetzt werden sie geschreckt
so muss das sein
weggeboxt von Zarya in 2k18
die Leute in Gameboy Chat ist so leise
braune Schild
ich muss zu unserem Winston Winston Winston
ja auf rein rein rein rein
ich kann halt alleine rein
wo ist denn der Winston jetzt, weg
fuck die Schild ist gleichzeitig gedrückt, Loops Zarya
man muss direkt, muss sich direkt rumtrennen was machen
vor allem wenn vorne nichts ist
oh die Balls geben jetzt was
komm ich muss dir Schild geben alter
card
wat
ok das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben die Craft
fu was haben wir da
Prost Neues, ja wünsche ich euch auch ein
Prost Neues
ich muss das wieder um
Spies Kill, jawoll
der Batman ist raus
was ist der da gestorben
back back back
muss ich die wieder auf
schieb weiter
weg weg weg weg
was haben wir wo ist, Braune Schild Schild Schild
nein nein nein nein nein
so nicht so nicht
Meuer ist so cancer zu hitten ey
jawoll
ein Scherz Zarya ganz gut funktioniert
ich bin gerade dabei mich ein bisschen auf das Game zu konzentrieren
aber wisst ihr was man hier an schön sieht dass es egal ist erstmal was du für einen Rank hast
du musst im Team spielen wollen das war jetzt mit Sicherheit nicht die Vollendung des Teamplays
gucken dass ich mal unseren Chat lauter kriegt das ist doch der Witz der First Agonix
ich weiß nicht wie das geht
Alter
müsste ein Fight halten oder zwei
ja Torb ist
als der mage
mal gucken geht ja erst in halb stunde los
mal so wenig spielen ich fühle mich mit den meisten hellen übelst unsicher gerade das ist der wahnsinn deswegen ist gut dass wir hier so ein bisschen matches spielen wo es im Endeffekt Komplex geht
ein Stückchen zurück klar wenn die kommen
zurück ein bisschen rein
zurück
immer noch halb
da müssen wir mit mehreren leuten da hin
du kommst nicht weg
scheiße
es war überhaupt es war überhaupt nicht notwendig dahinter zu gehen
0 3D
was RIP Ears warum
so ich muss mal gucken wie ich den Voice Chat lauter krieg
alles laut Fuck geschrien hast du okay
es geht mit der Musik jetzt ab
spielt mal king of the hill ja das können wir machen
es geht mit der ersten
Okay, jetzt habt ihr wenigstens auch ein Bronze-Silber-Spieler, da ist das wieder ein bisschen fairer.
Wieso? Wir haben auch ein Bronze-Spieler, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ja, jetzt bist du wieder da.
Ja, wünsche ich dir auch, Yoni-Backslash.
Das ist super, was geheim zu halten, wenn man in den Chat schreibt und ich streame.
Was hört sich besser an?
2K 16 oder 2K 18?
2K 17.
Eigentlich hört sich dieses ganze 2K irgendwie fast richtig hängen geblieben an.
Aber ich hab mich da mittlerweile so dran gewöhnt.
Na dann, rufen wir ihn mal. Easy, kannste mitspielen.
Kein Bock oder was? Null.
Was war denn das?
So, auf geht's.
Ja, du bist wieder da, oder? Ich vermute mal.
Ich geh mal davon aus, dass du wieder da bist.
Hoffentlich mal zumindest.
Da ist er doch, easy.
Jetzt kannst du mal wieder meine Lucio-Skills hier rausholen.
Mega, kein Mei, bitte.
Das ist voll 2016.
Das ist Beta.
Ja, ja, die Wand ist voll Evolution-mäßig. EA-like.
Es ist jetzt übrigens, ist der Chat lauter?
Das ist der äußerst gewöhnungsbedürftige Teamkomp, die wir hier haben.
Man versteht die Leute jetzt, oh, immerhin.
Ja, ich hab das gefunden. Irgendwie stand das auf 3%.
Hinter dir, Anna, hinter dir.
Ich hab Schiss.
Ich kann wenig dagegen machen gerade, wir müssen drauf.
Der steht da noch drin.
Ich brauch Heal, Max.
Ja, ich komm hinter.
Die sind viel zu gesplattet.
Die sind mega gesplattet.
Wir sind auf dem Spot.
Schieß dem Pferd in den Arsch.
Was?
Tschüss.
Huge Play.
Nee, Doomfist, so nicht.
Wie um alles in der Welt haben wir das gewonnen.
Huge Plays.
Da waren aber ein paar ganz gute Lucio Plays dabei.
Lucio flutscht noch.
Er ist kein Healer.
Hab ich das Gefühl, oder wird die Musik immer lauter gerade?
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Gefühl.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Gefühl.
Ich hab das Gefühl, ich hab das Gefühl.
Nein.
Deswegen ist Lucio nice.
Ich hab gleich Ulf hier.
Spot.
Massive G-Baited.
Ich war's nett.
Alter, das ist ja echt mal anstrengend.
Das war aber echt ein Lucio-Gameplay, was man eigentlich aufnehmen könnte.
Ich teilweise hatte da ein paar nice Sachen.
Ding. Ding.
Oder auch nicht.
Was war denn jetzt für eine Map?
Da mohten Max Eiskalt für sich selber, ja.
Ich wusste, ich wusste einfach, er hat so den Fingern gejoggt.
Das kann man machen.
Yoshi wäre ich auch für.
Sie sollten sich mal, sie sollten sich endlich mal ihren Scheiß zusammenkriegen und Demoman Peak in Overwatch einbauen.
Ich bin so fort dabei.
Ich spiele bestimmt Genji.
Ich habe jetzt gestream sniped.
Warum spielst du nicht mehr mit deinem Main?
Weil ich es seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt habe.
Ich dachte mir, ich mache meinen einfachen neuen Account, weil ich das Game eh wieder zu großen Teilen, zumindest auf halbwegs anständigem Level wieder lernen muss.
Neuer Account.
Ist das das mit der Brücke, das ist das mit der Brücke.
Da ist Reinhardt vielleicht.
Da wäre so eine D.Va besser, weil Reinhardt fliegt mir hier ganz gerne mal runter gegen die Fahrer.
Ja, genau wie es dir eher gesagt, so ist es.
Oder doch keine Fahrer oder doch nicht.
Schadenquats.
Keine, da geht gerade nicht viel.
Er wünscht dir auch Kommenze.
Kommenze?
Common Sense.
Kommenze.
Kommenze hast du mir auch nicht gehört.
Regroupen.
Regrouporn.
Pusht rein, pusht rein.
Ist hier noch was?
Nicht overextenden.
Ah ja, chill, chill, chill.
Willst du reinspringen, Mann?
Ja.
Double Allpower.
Komm zu mir, wenn du hier brauchst.
Next XQC hier.
Irgendwas lebt.
Ich glaube, pushen die links?
Etwas.
Ja.
Nein, die müssen pumpen.
Der hat Earth Shatter, der kokt schon so.
Haha.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das sei auf dem...
Asphania.
Gold Damage.
Gold Damage, Leute.
Gold.
Tristan Place.
Egal, ob Nano boostet oder nicht.
Ja, Yoshi, manchmal rage man einfach.
Sag noch mal bitte, ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Ich guck mal.
Könnte sein, dass der geswitcht hat.
Lass mal gucken.
Wir haben den Shunk.
Die lauschen im Stream, das kannst du nicht machen.
Das nie, der Streamsnipe ist real, ja.
Heimlich lauschen.
Irgendwas puffen.
Ihr müsst aus dem Chalk raus.
Geht aus dem Chalk raus, geht einfach.
Tracer swebt hinten bei mir.
Ich war ein bisschen zu schnell, sorry.
Ich kann euch im Chalk wieder heilen.
Ja, ja, ich komm wieder weg.
Lass die mal poschen, ich bin oben.
Geht aus dem Chalk weg, bitte.
Der Creel, rechte Seite, allein.
Villain.
Fuck.
Der hat mir mitpushen müssen, hat alle mitpushen müssen.
Nein, halb.
Der holt es hier.
Tanks links, tanks links.
Ich hab gedacht, ich kann aus der Tür rauskicken.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Hundert pro.
Sleeps.
Der Gengu ist da tot.
Irgendwie sind die Matches lustigerweise nicht so knapp, wie ich gedacht hätte.
Jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es.
Okay, machen wir noch eins.
Man hätte ja sagen können, dass jetzt alle gleich Placements suchen wollen.
Also ich mach die Placements morgen.
Also Jax, falls du gerade Stream guckst, bis hier heute,
kannst du keine Placements mehr gebacken.
Jetzt ist er raus, okay.
Naja, wenn er lief, dann kann ich ihn auch nicht ins andere Team switchen.
Ah, nice, okay, easy.
Was haben wir jetzt noch für ein Land gekriegt?
Einen...
einen Diamond Player.
Map machen wir.
Spielen wir jetzt mal.
Dorado, Dorado.
Beste Map.
Also von den Rängen her sollte es relativ ausgeglichen sein.
Das Gegner hat Master, Master Diamonds.
Wir haben Bronze, Master.
Okay, ja gut, wir haben den Jax.
Da, der rechte alle.
Wie die Musik abgeht.
So, das jetzt.
Hast du eigentlich Plants vs. Zombies gefinished?
Nein.
Ich hab BDO gekreint.
Warum gucken mir eigentlich 100 Leute zu jetzt schon die ganze Zeit?
Also, irgendwie gibt es noch mehr No-Life-Leute, habe ich das Gefühl.
Yoshi, du guckst, seit du 13 bist.
Ja gut, ja gut, klar.
Natürlich kann es schon sein.
Ja, easy.
Lass mal runter.
Äh.
Alles, alles...
verreckt.
Was haben die denn? Was kann ich denn spielen?
Nein, wir, wir contesten eh nicht nochmal.
Moment, wir haben einen Reinhardt jetzt?
Hatten wir schon die ganze Zeit einen Reinhardt?
Das ist ziemlich bescheuert, dass ich Orissa genommen habe.
Ich muss noch ein Stückchen an die Ecke.
Jetzt haben wir das Schild des Todes hier am Start.
Ein Stückchen zurück.
Lass nicht direkt am...
Ich kann nicht mehr reden.
Mein Chat ist weg.
Mein Voice-Chat geht nicht mehr.
Hört ihr mich noch?
Leute, hört ihr mich noch?
Ja, ihr hört mich noch.
Ich kann mich jetzt so...
Hört mich noch auf das Game-Concept.
Ja, ja, ja, mich, okay.
Ohne Voice ist das echt doof.
Ich hab mich mal verpisst.
Ist aber nice geplockt, haben wir den in Reinhardt.
Oh oh, zu viel und scheiß Position.
Moment, was ist denn mit meinem scheiß Mikro los?
Geht jetzt Voice wieder?
Voice?
Hallo?
Stopp.
Okay, wenn wir den Reinhardt haben...
Egal, Orissa funktioniert gut.
Checks nicht?
Ist jetzt mein Voice kaputt?
Aber wir können schon noch ein bisschen stallen, easy.
Oh, ich hab Ulti, Brinkens vor sechs.
Es ist keiner im Team.
Hä?
Hallo?
Ah, WTF?
Was war denn das für ein Scheiß?
Voice-Bun.
Reaper flankt links oben.
Reaper kommt wieder links.
Scheiße.
Können wir das noch mal kontestieren?
Das passt schon einfach schön.
Oh, nice picks, nice picks.
Echo pickt den.
Done.
da wo hinsten will er es aber wissen
sehr riesenherzig
sagt mal leute jetzt mal was ganz was anderes war eine ganz andere frage an euch
guckt jemand von euch speedruns oder speedrun jemand selbst zufällig
getting over it, ganz random frage ich gebe es zu aber ich würde gerne ein getting over it speedrun zeigen
und irgendwie ist es schwierig da an deutsche runner ranzukommen oder zu finden
die irgendwie auch eine zeit haben die nicht zehnmal langsamer ist wie die
besten getting over it speedruns das ist übelst geil guckt euch guckt euch das
mal an, das ist mega geil, sag mal heute sieht das stream gut aus oder fällt mir gerade so auf so 720p 48 fps
ich finde es echt scharf und es ruckelt nichts, sieht top aus warum spielst du nicht mehr mit deiner main
weil ich bis season 3 quasi ich habe ja nur bis season 3 gespielt also ich habe seit season 3 nicht
mehr gespielt nachdem ich das game auf so ein bisschen höherem level wieder komplett neu lernen muss
habe ich mir gedacht mach mal einen neuen account, dann kannst du es in ruhe üben
ja getting over it speedruns sind nur einmal interessant für dich das wäre optimal für ein video
ja schon da
ich habe das mal für einen sicheren fire strike verwendet
schreckt
machst du die placement matcher sein das sind noch viewer games noch since viewer games
ja massi massi cheat
huge chatter huge massive shut down
240hz monitor ist gut vielleicht vielleicht lasse ich mich doch mal chebaten und holen wir ein
was war ich da ich drinne na gut aufhauen wird schon recht haben
ja meine massi ja aber selbst die massi retten sie gerade nicht
achte achte achte
oh jetzt hat er mich gebatet
du willst die consultant karriere ich spiele
Okay Leute, ich bin fertig für heute, war sehr nice, schöner No-Live-Stream.
Also Leute, wir waren aus, war ein sehr schöner Stream.
Hab Bock gemacht und je nachdem was ihr jetzt auch macht, viel Spaß dabei und wir sehen
uns, alles klar, bis morgen, tschüss.
Tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute.